you know the drill tell us if you can
hear us can you sense can you hear us
our presence the audience this is such
good introductory live streaming the
audio I wanted to start can you hear us
we need to hear a comment we need to see
comments oh la familia it said we had a
bunch of people waiting in the chin in
the chapter this to go live and now now
oh there we are here we go Brandon
Jessica be in here we got Biff Tannen
ISA what's up benissa happy birthday you
guys can hear us I wanted to kick this
off immediately with saying happy
birthday to Anissa a liver
she has been an incredible incredible
incredibly kind human being orcs in an
ER and she's helping out the community
immensely and has been incredibly loving
to us is just a sweet human being even
my girlfriend approves and that's a rare
feat these days she doesn't prove of
anyone I interact with or anything I do
in my life so thank you and ISA for
being you
hey it's also Joel Lockhart's birthday
what's up buddy happy birthday to you
too doubling up so yeah we normally do
these live streams on like Friday or
Saturday but I just thought it would be
fun today to go live because Anissa
requested it and she has been so sweet
to us so I was like sure we'll do a live
stream today so who's on the chat right
now all late to the party and Niraj
Krishnan just to keep it straightforward
our live streams are very much like
we're just hanging out okay doesn't get
further more kicking it or not you're
not like these other live streams you
know professional here with information
and a structured program of content and
today's theme tell us your favorite
youtubers and YouTube channels and we'll
kick it off in a sec oh actually we just
got a super chat hear from Carter
Lovejoy art heir who listed one of my
favorite youtubers Chris stuckman hey
thanks Carter loved her for the
contribution click right here
yet Stockman ice to do tttttt yeah I
think Chris Stockman like in terms I'm
gonna work off of your super chat here
Chris stuckman and like Jeremy John's
are probably the biggest movie critics
on YouTube and I love how their styles
are just so different
Christopher if you go back to Chris
Stockman's earlier videos he was a
little bit more goofy and then he became
like an analytical guy I think he's
always been analytical but I think it
was around the time he wrote his novel
we leaned in - yeah yeah where Jeremy
John's has been pretty consistent and by
the way Jeremy John's one of my all-time
favorite youtubers we gotta meet him in
person yeah actually times I remember
when we did the josh mokuba show yeah ho
we were being in out was magical we were
interviewed right after Jeremy Jones was
in Jeremy John's doesn't really know us
but he decided to stick around to watch
our interview and my fitting all the
Mike one of my favorite moments was I
was telling some story and he's laughing
so hard I saw I looked off and I saw him
go back that brief glimpse of an image
right there is one of my favorites so oh
man Carter thanks for saying thanks for
saying what you might call it picker
stuck me oh we got a ton of people
Melanie Faber is here failed tail what's
up Kayla so yeah guys thoughts our
favorite ones who else is in the chat
here happy Jenkins whose charm ex I've
never heard of char max oh I don't know
we should look them up
okay so sit Joel Luke Luke art 101 facts
is a great Josh friends point 101 facts
that is it that is a fantastic channel
by the way you know there's a have you
seen this channel before if you guys
have not seen the cosmonaut variety hour
he is hysterical he is not only like
great at analyzing but he's also really
really funny like I'd be intimidated to
get into an argument with that guy yeah
he seems incredibly smart but he's also
very funny John who do you got oh man I
mean piggybacking off that for whatever
reason cosmonaut right
made me think wisecrack I'm a big fan of
wisecrack my favorite channel is
probably a needle drop with you know
your boy Anthony Fantan Oh even though
he's not everyone's cup of tea I know
but I just like his videos I like both
of his channels a lot double toasted
though if we're going back go all the
way back spill comm double toasted
that's where it starts for me I mean I
remember when when we fought double toes
were the first ones to verse double
toasted in the movie trivia Schmoe down
and I made sure that you like his jaw I
mean the John jumped at the opportunity
to verse that you know and he even wrote
down [ __ ] Corey on his on his knuckles
yeah and people thought that was a mean
thing is little did they know it was a
term of endearment because it's an
actual in the know when it comes like a
slogan exactly yeah that was still I
thank you for everything that you did to
make that happen because that was one of
the coolest nerd moments ever to be able
to play against them yeah and I didn't
never seen their work so if you guys are
just tuning in today's livestream is
tell us about your who your favorite
youtubers are and it's always fun to
know who else is being watched wreck do
thanks so much dude markiplier ooh
gotta love mark you know what I could
add on to this I've heard markiplier is
uh is an amazing boss cool your second I
thought I was gonna go the opposite way
but a lot of these really big YouTube
channels you hear about the ins and outs
of certain companies once you get to a
certain stage once you get to a certain
stage left off it happened what but yeah
markiplier here is like an incredible
boss yeah yeah he's not a tick like what
everyone else thought hey I mean you
know this is easy to hide a dick behind
a shiny friendly Vermeer that's very
modern here well thank you record deal
for that Achievement Hunter never heard
of Achievement Hunter mr. beast I think
that sounds familiar to me
Leonardo it's very kind of you to say
glad to make you laugh
scooter lüders and Brandon Brandon Roger
what else philosophy tube not bad what's
up me me and oh and the birthday girl
herself hey Gabi Kawai wow wow wow
that's the love that we get after all
that we've done for you that you haven't
returned in any way shape you know it's
fair technically he came into the world
before you so thanks for super chatting
us on your birthday yeah it's like when
you would go to school and then you you
were the one with murdering Donuts so
that maybe you'll like me I want to come
over like that's what's expected it's
happy birthday Anissa you're a beautiful
woman
thank you and Jabby kauai yes he's uh
he's a solid youtuber that one he's well
he's doing well starter reactions after
us he saw how well this channel was
doing and now he's trailing behind it
Tariq Rath wants us to talk about
Tennant what's there to talk about
Erik's bars there you go Erik chop to
que era hodgetwins of course
tyro Magnus who wouldn't who wouldn't
Tyrone Magnus I would Tyrone
like a man chase is lumping us in with
blind wave jacksepticeye Jeremy Johnson
retro reef who got a chick Connor I
gotta check out retro replay - I mean I
think we deserve to be in this category
we've earned it blind wave is really
good ooh of course I can't bring up this
topic of favorite youtubers without
mentioning red letter media
oh absolutely my favorite I mean to them
I got you and I got Olivia red letter
media so really should take you there
really easy channel - yep
and also um you know I really love the
channel Screen Rant I do despite
whatever flak they get but Ryan George
got a shout pitch meetings riding George
but also his own solo YouTube channel
the sketches he does a first year like
this is kind of similar to the pitch
meeting but once you adjust to it it's
really funny yeah yeah a lot of you you
actually that was through a patron that
I first saw Michael be Michael be thank
you you have literally introduced one of
our I think usually favorite video
series thank you Oh PJ thank you so much
PJ hey buddy what's up guys I have been
watching you guys for years lately I
haven't been able to watch the live
streams over the weekend so I finally so
watch the whole thing on Monday while
working finally made one hey welcome I'm
glad you could finally be here PJ you
actually go back and watch the live
streams because normally what happens is
we do the live streams accumulates
whatever views yeah and then it might
get like a couple thousand I get like a
couple hundred extra views over the
course of a week pretty much clean up
everything in the stream I just assume
like whoever was here with that without
the only time the stream is ever gonna
be watched so thank you for doing that
PJ love your photo by the way mmm-hmm
look like a very I would trust you yeah
you could either be like a villain and
one of those like serial killer shows or
like the the best friend next door those
oh you know dude who like the whole know
that you're like the protagonists are
treat this guy better one Dale just
seriously compliment people nah why not
my style
hmm all right so ooh oh my god my good
friend Iman in you guys of course nerd
chronic thanks so much dude buddy Eric
and nerd chronic he's the editor and
were so many of the shows that have gone
up here on YouTube of the reactions and
he also edits for movie trivia Schmo
down so so really kind dude he also
tried hooking John up with Iman snow a
wonderful reactor didn't pan out
yeah and out John was one of this is one
of the rare cases where John wasn't the
type for a specific girl wow you know I
was really hurt by that but you guys are
watching montz knows channel really good
reactor that I can because it's just too
painful late to the party is in this
right now what's going on late to the
party good to see you here dude oh dude
and dudette late to the parties telling
stories here about you know late to the
party you're stealing away from our am
our time to shine late to the party your
cheer no Shawn you share your Jeremy job
stories and everyone's is talking with
you cuz they never want to talk about
Jeremy Johnson which by the way Jeremy's
not so hot finally put up a review for
the raid redemption watch that review
was it good was it good review yeah good
while you his room this review is good
if you're drunk twin coconuts
we got Maria Hammond in the chat saying
love John Roca yes he's a good guy
hasn't invited me on his channel even
though I brought them on here several
times Dan Mueller and I'm a damn er damn
Mueller is Oh interesting politician but
he's got a great YouTube channel
oh it's dim felt Tamara yeah yeah Daniel
are theis flashback to one of our old
elementary teachers actually Maria
Hammonds listing like all the channels I
watch regularly John Roca damn merle who
has a great new youtube channel you guys
got a go damn Merle's youtube channel
sen network Schmoe down fandom
entertainment SJ you of course a lot of
love for corger crew in this chat as
well and the flick pick g beats nice new
flick pics great whenever he wants to
talk to me about a potential product
placement to see if we got hit up about
them too oh is the kind of relationship
you want to build Oh hung out with flick
pick in Europe and in America one time
mainly in Europe oh he is as buff as you
would he's probably buffer now my god I
want to see Tennant
tarik okay so Carter Lovejoy's asking
about this gonna sidestep thank you by
the way Carter for the super chat The
Last of Us to leaks I I haven't I've
heard like minor things about it but I
love that game too like there's some
some [ __ ] will react to leaks but for
Last of Us
I was like
I'm not gonna do that with the last of
us I heard some stuff didn't really make
me happy I don't want to spoil it for
anyone here but from what I've heard in
case there are people here that's super
in the in the last room who are you know
not one and a half [ __ ] room for them
from what I've heard I'm very skeptical
about it
that being said I'm definitely still
buying the game I also say this keep in
mind - here's here's what I really got
to point out my favorite video game
franchise of all time is Metal Gear
Solid
now if the leaks came out for Metal Gear
Solid 2 that you only play a Solid Snake
for like 20 minutes and the rest of the
game you're playing as some dude named
right people would be furious sad is
true they would be absolutely furious
matter the first time I played I was
kind of annoyed I'm like what the [ __ ]
snake but then he get really into the
game and end up being amazing one of the
best games of all time so I don't know
it's not like the main thing people are
complaining about with Last of Us - but
it's one of the complaints that you play
is right in for all of Last of Us - but
yeah that's that's all saying that cuz I
don't want to ruin the things with epic
Rap Battles of History how can you not
bad lip reading one of the best YouTube
channels ever as well ooh ooh what Niraj
st. Patrick H will and I'd love a metric
gauge Williams yeah in fact I was really
bummed I didn't get to meet him at last
Comic Con you try actually talking to a
trick h1 well no but he was apparently
at that rooftop we got to that one night
like right before we were there oh
really oh yeah no I loved his video
essays and his like creative in the
style of shorts I think his channels
great Jimmy champagne never heard of him
Eric horseman Eric what did I tell you
about not spending your stimulus check
it's so much in the last lives I mean
that's very sweet here thank you
but I gotta say Eric why is your profile
pic
the real rejects tattoo that you got
what else are you doing on YouTube I'm
not gonna you know okay Eric actually
introduced us to the tribe thank you by
the way Eric such a major secret thank
you
you're far too kind the try Channel Eric
introduced us to the try Channel they
are a really one that they're really
funny they're really funny guys oh yeah
watching them try different like foods
and stuff alcohol beverages yeah I think
the one they introduced me to us too was
like one of the one of the drinking ones
I tried channel doesn't get enough love
I think I think they deserve a lot more
with a lot more attention
yeah I think I think there might be
bigger overseas because of so everyone I
noticed and there's like Irish or
something right I think it's like an
Irish base yeah yeah because yeah it's
often you know people from the UK
reactants like typically the try channel
is a good one
Eric I want to tell you about a legit
nightmare I had I have I had a nightmare
that involve you I had a nightmare
that's that I shut down the real rejects
and all I was thinking about was Eric
and how he got a [ __ ] tattoo I was
like I gotta go to Atlanta to go visit
motivation in the dream I have to make
this right because I have to I have to
hurry over to Atlanta to at least talk
with Eric because I didn't want him to
get rid of the tech this is an actual
dream I had I think two nights ago or
something like that and then I woke up
and I was like okay we'll keep the
channel alive because I don't want to
deal with the trip to Atlanta I can't
afford right now thank you Eric yeah
good so just if in the chats at Joe
exotic TV now's the time get him those
stream points woo Nikki and Stephen you
know there are some great reaction
channels out there guys that I would
love to I think I have like did I do I
not have a book to market anymore oh
yeah cinema siblings it's a great
reaction channel Shay is another
wonderful reaction Channel crazy couple
great reaction shell embryo
love che these are something there's
there's a lot of great reaction channels
out there and so I recommend just a few
of those if if you're interested
emergency awesome yep good yeah one two
more one two more love for the tri
channel what's up hey okay we got a lot
of pewdiepie love in the chat was
watching PewDiePie is he's still funny
he's he's made relationship with the man
uh yeah I don't know whether or not he's
done something racist without realizing
bored done something that affects the
entire YouTube ecosystem in all fairness
Beauty I got too much blame yes he got
way too much play it was not necessary
draw yeah broke the youtubes back but I
what I love about what PewDiePie mean as
long as like meme reviews and reaction
stuff and I think III think he does more
of what he genuinely loves doing and I
feel like that's actually made his
channel better that's good yeah I still
watch PewDiePie tryna act like I don't
you I watch a lot of people I actually
Peter Pacheco thank you dude if this
pandemic happened between infinity Wars
and endgame what would had done at the
box office they would have released it
on P VOD and then AMC and Regal would
have been like we're not playing Disney
movies anymore
we're not playing most movies anymore
Peter Pan check oh that's a cool that's
a that's like a great name it's always
good to have a name that has like the
same first letter for first and last
night some alliteration going new
Italian Pacheco
are you Italian is it Pacheco or
pancetta Pacheco Pacheco I'm looking
this up this is this is what the Lay's
most strange Pacheco name the meaning
noble one let's hope you
up to that name there buddy who are you
are you noble or are you a scoundrel if
it happened yeah I mean like the only
way that that would be in any way
fortunate is if the pandemic was like
really wraps up nicely well yeah I mean
if that I think endgame would have
gotten delayed I have thought I like
your question a lot hold on hold on I
like your question a lot because I've
thought about that what would happen if
if if the pandemic occurred between
infinity or an end game but I honestly
feel like any game might have even made
more money because you know would have
been great
oh you don't have been really cool would
have been cool to some extent because if
infinity war happened and everyone gets
wiped out in that movie right then the
pandemic occurs and then a real-life
terrible things happening and then when
theaters reopen at the first movie to
open up was endgame that would have been
like I'm so glad the feeders are back
yes it would have been a sensational
experience that would have been that
would it would be perfect but also like
there's also a horrible in between stuff
yeah might be a little too real all
right bio one my favorite Elton John
song is I'm still standing you're sated
you can rest easily now Bernie John do
your Bernie Sanders impression my
favorites real rejects the markiplier is
that your Obama it's a little well he's
got some when he gets to chill he's got
up a little bit of me Obama was your
Obama no this is my elbow my favorites
real rejects markiplier that's my oboe
it's better that's right what did you
Bernie any of sentence I need a full on
sentence well that's really sweet of you
thank you Bernie Bernie really sweet of
you I wanna is Bernie you or your cat
you know I read this reminds me I resent
we went to go visit our friend Patrick
Hogue on his birthday this is
for quarantine situation don't worry
before we went to go contaminate pasture
before everyone starts yelling it yeah
went to go visit Patrick on his birthday
and I've had over the years I've had a
lot of people on uncommon say you look a
lot like markiplier and I've always
joked saying I look like if super like
to me markiplier is like a Superman like
that's the way he carries himself you
boys like people have told me you got a
good smile and you got a you got a nice
voice and then I look at markiplier and
he's like he's like he has those
qualities but it's so much more than me
like so much better
wow we're striking right well all you
have to do is you need to increase your
testosterone so that your voice drops
that much deeper but then and and you've
already got the guns though no market
powers really like way more buff and
he's like yeah I am like when a
celebrity hat what I am - markiplier is
like when a celebrity has a twin brother
who is not as good
exactly there's someone in the chat who
says you look like a dollar store
markiplier that's my point
see I'm not even offended by that store
markiplier store that one guy from blind
way it works so what but when I went to
meet patty I met his when I went to go
see Pat I met his roommates for the
first time and the woman was looking at
me and I was female roommate and she was
looking at me and for a second I was
thinking oh maybe she's a fan of the
real rejects and then she goes haha you
know you look a lot like this guy named
markiplier have you heard of he's on
YouTube make some great videos you
should do that all the time anyone has
ever said that to me in person was that
experience right there so all of you who
think that must be vintage yes right now
who's dr. wolf Ola I don't know dr. wolf
eeeh is that like a horror Saturday
morning like bad movie hostess no idea
who that is
alright I'm googling dr. wolf eula
please do please do please do
okay all right quarters a lot of
corridor crew I remember catching their
very first VFX artist react video I just
a first one yeah like I I started
watching at least that series right from
the beginning cuz it popped up cuz I was
already getting really into those like
it's not a channel but one of my
favorite things lately to watch on
YouTube is just when experts react and
stuff and yeah when that first one
dropped I was like oh this is a perfect
idea
and then yeah ever since then if when we
started doing reactions like damn now
like now I got to be more careful about
watching me when they Travis you know
who I like something that's not movie
related I really like the channel legal
eagle yeah that real lawyer reacts them
yeah I really get into that stuff even
breaks down you know TV and stuff
sometimes to just to tiger yeah i box at
night 23 that's the best time to box
because you can't see your shadow thank
you so much i box a night uh thank you
tyro magnus Duane and Jett Duane in jazz
or I didn't know who tweening jazz Berta
they were at two million followers
because there was there was a point
where it was like Gator Mardan us tyro
Magnus Hakkasan jinx and there's like a
handful of reactors and then I know
we're over time there's like a bunch of
other reactors emerged I never heard of
until they were like way past a million
followers between and jazz or one of
them they're really funny the normies
are a great youtube channel as well but
thank you for the compliment anytime you
you don't have to lump us I mean for
everyone who's like commenting here tell
us your favorite YouTube channels and I
really appreciate whenever you say real
rejects you know but I notice a lot of
you guys are saying and real rejects so
you don't you don't have to just say it
it's only authentic if we're in the
middle with the clump all box you at
night 23 if you if you don't actually
mean it I can hear your tone of voice
this doctor will feel a channel looks
like it's right up my alley actually so
I'm about to go down a new rabbit hole
thanks to y'all somewhat a desert
grizzly artists bringing up comic tropes
I would say comics explain
is another great especially if you want
to get the source material knowledge on
a lot of comic-book properties to look
good for a movie reviewer trailer
reaction comics explain comic story and
it's another good one you know I
definitely recommend them well and in
terms of another movie review channel of
someone who will be a lot bigger I think
is Shawn Chandler I think of a couple
people I mentioned him in here but Shawn
Chandler is a great movie reviewer as
well yeah ooh roosterteeth we actually
worked with them not long ago yeah they
gave us was Harley Quinn things Harley
Quinn thing and Anissa Oliver gave me
this shirt and this shirt see ooh for
her birthday she gives us stuff thank
you should work theory get Jabby is
another good channel absolutely shoot a
birdie I don't know what that is also
you know you got to point out my our
neighbors that cyber channel yeah where
is the list of be crazy crazy that cyber
channel I'm not other great YouTube
channels as well we're gonna tell them
how many shout outs they gets how it
should have ended seeing a lot of love
for them to hear how it ended
yes is he okay femme fatal tail
thank you sup thank you again I know
you've been here before thank you found
fails Kayla waters is that Kayla waters
Kayla waters what's up Kayla freshly
made one of the moderators on our
patreon exclusive just closed Georgia we
also have a public one if you want I
jump on there I actually made
achievement to hunter part of my gaming
sleeve and watching behind the scenes on
markiplier High series he's a total
sweetheart what does it mean I made it
she made hundred oh okay I get it I mean
all my gaming all right I got you
is that good this is good and live
stream content me going what does that
mean I'm glad for you
I would love to watch her behind the
scenes on that though especially because
like there are more of these choose your
own adventure series popping up more and
more of the place yes so like and and it
looks like it would be fun to watch him
do outtakes dude mark have you ever gone
back
because we did a reaction to markup
liars hi series and by the way Kayla
thanks for the discord and for patreon
and you know being you you're just
amazing to us but back - markiplier -
markiplier I I was like I want to show
this to Olivia and so I played I played
it with her and I went down different
she kept asking me like did you go this
way I'm like okay she'll go different
way like oh because uh choose your own
adventure kind of game if you guys
haven't played it yet and they there's
so much in that that I do not realize
how much they there I was like this is
like a whole other thing have you gone
back and plated at all oh my
it is massive okay massive like the
amount of expansion on Youku like a
different Island at one point she turns
into an animation I played it three
times so far oh yeah I saw markiplier is
an incredible feat and I feel like I
think I'm gonna play it again actually
it's a know what I'm feeling this week
incredible achievement - markiplier
and strange rebel gaming got a
Chateaubriand a while got a shoutout
Breanna white stranger little gaming saw
someone mention her and for someone who
is [ __ ] in one of the biggest games
of the year
she's killing it right now in the world
but you know she's still doing like her
live streams and such popcorn talk is
pretty red we've done a couple shows on
the popcorn talk Network we've done an
action-movie Anatomy a couple of times
Ben Bateman no way we know we shouldn't
we shouldn't bring up popcorn but we
can't now we've got Jose where there's
there's some things we're about to
cancel popcorn cancel culture all you
gotta do is like a little bit of a tone
also in terms of horror channels mister
nightmare I love what he does there I
saw him on the trending page recently
and I think it was the first time I'm
sure he's been on there before but I
think that was the first time I ever saw
him
on the trending page I used to love
Marble Hornets speaking of you know
creepy stuff on on YouTube Marble
Hornets and to the ark the little web
series based off the Slender Man that
like really helped kick off the the
craze right dead meat there's some dead
meat love dead meat James of course hmm
by the way dead meat giant like James a
Jenice is is actually like one of the
nicest guys you'll ever meet
he's a he has one of those personalities
in a video that is so nice yeah you're
like this guy here like this guy's
probably a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's probably
all about that hair we spent a lot of
time with him and he is like one of the
nicest people you'll ever meet
oh yeah Chelsea on the other hand she'll
show me his fiance oh my gosh you how
did you know
Chelsea's a sweetheart you've actually
gotten to do some pretty cool just like
engagements for promos for movies with
them and yeah there are they're good
cats
ooh cinemasins is there always gonna be
killing it and yes someone's asking I
did watch their everything wrong with
the rise of Skywalker I'm always gonna
watch their big stuff oh yeah oh yeah a
lot of it I've seen a lot of people shot
at cinema wins - Britney Lange thank you
keeping up the tradition are Canadian
Canadian dollar here keep it up the
tradition of changing the profile picked
every time she's here my favorite
channel is yours and david dobrik hello
guys how's it going I feel like I know
that name yeah I feel like I've seen him
on hot ones at least the best
interviewer he really got yeah Oh David
yeah he I am I actually recently learned
about david dobrik because i watch a
youtube channel called charisma on
command uh where I got all my charms
from uh-huh this is part of what they
teach to behave like this I watched
charisma on command
I saw a breakdown he did a David de
briques and then I led me to his channel
yeah good call good call I
I heard he's actually a really kind
human being too I hope according to the
breakdown on charisma on command yes you
can mathematically tell through those by
the way uh Brittany Lang what is that
photo oh my god there is looking
beautiful it looks like either Vegas or
how's it going Brittany I'll tell you
how it's going well
we'd never do live streams I've been on
this day of the week but seen in the
month so figured be a fun way to close
out the month yeah and if colleagues and
we so open it would be college weekend
beginning night is a party night for
college have you drink at all during
this pandemic
yeah actually not heavily no but however
here's something I have wanted Fri I've
never really learned how to mix drinks
and I like a good cocktail type of
person who like I'll have a good drink
to unwind can we just pause did you
catch yourself there you said I know you
wanted to say I like a good cocktail but
you ended at [ __ ] oh yeah gay jokes I do
like a good you'll see it I like a good
cocktail and I am learning to make them
so yeah I I have a drink every now and
again I have not had any alcohol this
entire pandemic you're missing you know
what that was one of the first they have
had a couple edibles that's the thing I
was I early on I haven't been to a store
in a while now but early on when this
pandemic and the lockdown was happening
I was so surprised to enter a mostly
empty Trader Joe's only to find that
their wine and liquor was overflowing no
one touched it I was like great I'll
just buy like six bottles a to bug truck
people are trying to be a little bit
healthy during this time yeah that's
good Brittany say hi to your family say
hi to your daughter so how do you dot a
[ __ ] I can't do that that's right she's
a little girl say hello to your daughter
for me from a kind gentleman named Greg
you tell your daughter that I said say
hi to your mother for me and thank you
Thank You Brittany all right who else
who else oh you guys listen here new
rock stars yes
of course one of the best channels you
know another great breakdown channel
Cinna fix highly recommends in effects
just right is another good one
nerdwriter as well Cinna fix to me like
they do these you might be confusing
might be a lead misled by their top by
their titles because sin affects will do
these top 10 videos but they're not just
these opinion based like you know top 10
superhero movies or something that it is
like watching a a film school video it's
like true film analysis so if you're
looking for like a top 10 or those like
in list video channels and they also do
like these videos of six ways the the
predator book is different or the six
ways the Rambo book is different than
the movie you know those kind of readers
but if you're looking for really
intellectual list videos I really
recommend sin affects heck yeah you you
know what's another one baby like [ __ ] I
do I just need to can we take a few
moments from Cox no I've been watching a
lot lately in fact she's in the chat
what's up Haley my friend turned me on
to bone Appetit
gourmet makes where a chef basically
takes candy snack food etc and then
reverse basically figures out how to
make it and then makes gourmet version
and then shares the recipe with you
that's really fun show you like cooking
someone saying in the chat ever you guys
heard about mr. Christian me we've
reacted a plenty of Mr Krabs's channels
and sometimes he hits me up I don't know
if there's anything that's happened to
his channel the way that questions
phrase makes it sound like something
something wrong happen well yeah did
something happened that we should have
heard about her or should we just all
know mr. preface because we should all
know this is a great YouTube shame he
does some of the best trick like though
you know if you guys don't know mister
crap just offhand he's one of those
channels that he does a lot of those
he's been brett chants like a little bit
more video essay style stuff but he he
does one of those channels that does
like captain america
okay what's what's one actual one the
avengers endgame trailer but but a once
upon a time in holly
what style okay and as editing is
perfect yeah superb editing anyway I was
on shrooms he was the one who did the
the what's a character one right video
essay I hope his video essays get bigger
Anisa this is your birthday so thank you
for your super keep bringing those
doughnuts are oh yeah the try guys I
have been watching them since they were
on BuzzFeed and since they left they
have grown into an amazing Channel they
are so funny fun fact actually I think
my buddy Charlie went school with one of
the try guys so uh I don't know which
guy no one's interested in that fact job
I'm citing no son true I lied because
anyone know charlie are people gonna
relate I have at least one person I know
of who can verify Charlie's exist I can
be like oh that's fascinating Charlie
but am I really going to give a [ __ ]
I mean he's been on the channel ins
before thank you guys if there's
anything you learned from this live
streaming from the super chats we've
gotten you gotta go watch the try you do
especially now that they're not feed
BuzzFeed unsolved yeah
I remember the first time Natalie sent
us one of those if they didn't block
some of our videos we'd still be
reacting a BuzzFeed unsolved that's the
one type of thing besides movie stuff
that I would love to react to if if
given the choice is just like more
spooky ghost things i binge watched a
bunch of F when I was I was preparing to
write something and I was like oh I'm
gonna watch this one video from BuzzFeed
unsolved and then it led to a binge
watch of BuzzFeed unsolved where I
didn't write that night watching a bunch
of buttons all with Olivia thank you
Andy so anytime you have a happy
birthday again dear yeah every time you
comment we're just gonna wish you a
happy birthday
cinema wins oh I'm not as into cinema
Wednesday
I mean like cinemasins just more fun
because you're criticizing and you're
nitpicking stuff but cinema wins is a
that's a positive inducing channel I
positive I like the concept way more
than cinemasins and yet I find
cinemasins the more compelling show yeah
it's like I I love what cinema wins is
doing and I feel good about watching it
but yeah there's something that is just
different tonally that isn't as hooky
Alfred threats Benjamin the third
security guard
oh no we fell behind I was trying damn
I'm trying to balance the comments and
then show love to the super chat people
as well instead of all they doing the
superjet yes and now we have followed by
and we can't flash them on screen okay
it's okay okay but okay hey away may but
I could do this really fast we can share
the right side screen this one that's
thawing let me go into uh and they're
right here look what he look what he
gave us one of these Oh dick I've talked
to Alfred Thank You Alfred I've talked
to him on patreon and his passion is in
one and open up its own security
business one day that's what's up I've
never met someone with a passion like
that what the [ __ ] are you doing it's
gone horribly horribly no we can't we're
not the technical guys that's why I
preface this live stream with we just
hang out ain't gonna be the [ __ ] John
Campea
I gotta say too I think like the the
people after they've left Collider or
like lost some other shows on Collider
the like people like Roxie stryer John
Roca were right Riley they're live
streams are really really great live
stream shows almost as if they were used
to being in live stream and video drew
is another gray one too so thank you
thank you there Alfred okay so let's
let's go
no cosmic wonder love I do this yes
all right cool yeah so a cosmic wander
yes of course I love that guy as a
matter of fact he sent me a text today
cosmic wonder dead meat is not a Nimrod
take it back a chi Pennypacker
he is timing how he launched another
video on his comic channel there's some
fun behind the scenes when not on
youtubers text each other people I know
are friends with each other if people
were like Greg who's in your contacts
I'd say Warren from the cosmic one and
Jabby kawaii
markiplier Will Smith Jack Black yeah
Jack glad you love Jack Black's channel
I find that to be such an uncomfortable
question whenever I see celebrities ass
I didn't like radio interviews like
who's in your contact list what you're
feeling right now who's in your list at
the same time and they're going I want
to [ __ ] know who's in that guy's
phone who's inkjets out to Kevin Nealon
Oh girlfriend reviews is fun we've seen
at least one of those girlfriend reviews
is a great YouTube channel absolutely
who said that that we ought to hear new
girlfriend reviews amen to that
Justin Fernandez there's alright so who
are we behind on also to Jack L or Jack
well Johnson Jon shattered another one I
would like to now shout out Michael
where the rad-brad is such a great guy
and an awesome gamer that's good to know
that's good to know a lot of Campea love
will power Nick f30 there's this guy who
from who often reports on like fun I
don't know about it's not always fun but
like dramatic news was a quartering oh
the quartering the quartering funny guy
yeah - check them out all the time but I
I I'm I'm able to disagree but not hate
but still enjoy certain be amused by
like I don't know
red letter media is arguably my favorite
YouTube channel but I don't a lot of
time I disagree with them but I always
got a major kick out of watching them
all the time I'll be on the trailer did
she say that said be on the trail do it
John and ok so then who an Arras up
buddy I mean did you say this already
for free Willems
Jabby Kawai our stupid reactions women I
know are stupid reactions yes you can
they do Bollywood stuff as well and
that's not funny John that's not only I
make fun of you you make fun of me my
egos fragile and hurt sorry I'm already
called discount markiplier everywhere I
go
today David so is funny real rejects
thanks no Raj Raj has always been so
sweet to us but Niraj to do they give
you as much attention as we give you
Niraj why is it and the real rejects
well I'm pretty sure we give you more
attention than all these other ones
combined all know the best isn't saved
for last
I'm the one you remembered Lions just
saying and dead meat James is not a
Nimrod he's awesome yeah but he does
like Green Day h3h3
their podcast is great their podcast is
podcast is [ __ ] great yeah I was just
watching Ethan talk about mark McGrath
from Sugar Ray's cameo economy thing cuz
he's your friend
yeah yeah he calls me his first names
like John I need your advice for the
podcast man hi
how [ __ ] weird does this look to you
guys the fact that we have like on your
end of viewing looks like they're
usually your tube used to have it so you
could just make the super chat menu pop
out on its own little window and now the
new admittedly kind of nice little
dashboard does not make this part easy
John tell the audience here another
YouTube channel that you really love
that you're promoting boo I like the
school of life they're a more
philosophical based channel a little
more thoughtful they kind of tack
different social concepts and stuff like
that usually paired with interesting
little animations I enjoyed them quite a
bit I also like Vsauce a lot which you
know they went YouTube premium a while
ago but a Vsauce like really cool
science-based videos and science-based
curiosities and stuff like that else man
I'll so you know it shouts out to a
cartoon show that's only got one episode
out right now I think but has been hotel
I think is on YouTube and that is it
called has been Hotel haz bi n it's this
independently produced cartoon the
animation is insane it's it's it's more
of an adult cart animation adult cartoon
but uh it's pretty wild and pretty
impressive especially again for being
something that was like self produced
your or you know independently produced
the Jenkins show
thank you for your super chat
contribution buddy I wish I could flash
it on screen but we have fallen behind
here I think we're gonna get a different
streaming service until we can figure
this out like we're probably gonna
switch the stream labs like everyone
else right now we're using stream yard
and so we often fall behind on the
comments and I don't fall behind it's
just really no we like to give attention
to some where some things are
interacting with here and so then we are
not able to flash stuff on screen like
how desert grizzly art said that but
then eventually he'll go away
but the Jenkins show thank you dude is
that an actual YouTube channel yo yo you
guys you have to check out the behind
the scenes for mob vs. ahsoka you guys
are awesome you got me making my own
channels so thank you we got the Jenkins
show to surface several YouTube channel
five or six YouTube channels he's got he
has five friends and they all start up
five or six YouTube channels pretty soon
that revenue is gonna just be flowing
upward and you guys ever been in a
multi-level marketing company because if
not what if I could show you how to make
double the money in half the hours
you're working right now I can't
remember what I was watching but they
they have vitamins and in my trunk my
entire Denton rich to wine that will
help you
your hair I was reading some I was
watching something that I can't remember
exactly what but the guy said if you
take that theory of like if you bring
five friends and they bring five friends
you can only do that for 13 cycles
before you've taken up the entire world
or something like that its population so
while the system works for some there
will always be people at the bottom of
the pyramid yes thirteen times that's it
like you know okay I'm figuring out a
temporary solution to show some super
chats on screen it's not working doesn't
work it's not the logo you got to put it
in the overlay oh my god y'all I'm doing
everything I can do this part No Who am
I gonna blame if things go wrong yeah
and you take the upper half positive
Stephen great music reactor and cute as
[ __ ] I would agree with that positive
statement most definitely is who's the
guy
they thank you Eric by the way for
mentioning positive Stephen you guys
should go check out his youtube channel
grape he is oh he is a wonderful music
record thank you for the super chat by
the way dude no life check no life shag
shag is a spell of that guy's reaction
oh my god his music video reactions are
so good he's great
Dante is great you know who's chanting
dante obvious ik related but caleb city
his sketches are so funny though he does
by himself yeah yeah chaos is really
[ __ ] and also there's a lot of people in
the music sphere Shawn see I watched a
swirl I forgot the name that yeah uh wow
it's gonna I don't know I just had a
whole brain meltdown just there um okay
that's great great there John thanks I
was trying to think of spectrum pulse
and then I just melted my brain I mean
what do you think about BuzzFeed
Humphrey I like BuzzFeed fine enough I
mean I know that a lot of people
complain about their kind of restrictive
working practices like you know if
you're working for BuzzFeed you can't do
anything else and I don't know if that's
true I
know if it's true right now but that is
that has been true like I've known I've
had friends of friends who are actors
for example like who couldn't no acts
because they worked at BuzzFeed
real yeah so BuzzFeed there are some
great things about them there's some
really cool content that they have and I
appreciate some of the kind of positive
stuff they try to put out there but um
you know there's uh there's some
problematic stuff under the hood over
there
as I understand it anyway I've heard
John wrote cos very abusive to his
guests really yeah
so I want everyone to know that right
now and next time you see John Roca go
live you make sure to tell him
real rejects said you're very abusive to
your guests I'm trying to get John Roca
cancelled with no proof with John Roca I
can't tell you what it is but it was
terrible John rogue is a great guy does
a sweetie
Melanie Thank You Melanie Thank You
Melanie Madeline are one of our patrons
to besides you guys blind waive the
normies and the Tryg there's so much
love for the try guys they were honestly
the like I don't know if it had last
people I expected but I wasn't expecting
so much love for the try guys in this
chat today oh we got a birthday coming
up it's coming up on Cinco DeMayo so
remember to do a shot of tequila and
celebrate with me
oh I know we will melody tequila time we
will John we'll be sending you so many
nude pics that's right too many nude
pics you'll get to see my boobs and his
ding-a-ling right all of the above John
has a wonderful ding-a-ling thanks Greg
to own once I've seen yours Mars was
asking for something for her doctor's
report and John sent it to his mom right
I keep hoping it was it was a penis your
and your mom is gonna watch this life
bound to happen and then I want her to I
want her to directly cause she's your
mom is never directly in all like
whatever decades we've known each other
she's never directly called me but one
day I want her to call me
just be like I don't appreciate talking
about my son's penis on during the real
rejects livestream I am really excited
for was actually a really sweet woman
but he's great she's hip to she's got
good taste and stuff jacksepticeye I'm
seeing a lot of love for him in the chat
right now jacksepticeye I saw him in
person once you want to guess what movie
that was I'll give you guys 20 minutes
of silence to guess I'll just tell you
Avengers and yeah someone went up to him
and asked for a photo and he said not
here and then left the theater he didn't
any Avengers and you could easily say
that tell that story in a version that
makes it sound like jacksepticeye is a
dick or something yeah but I just don't
think he wanted to open up the door to
have other people like start clamoring
around but it's so easy to take a story
like that and go I saw Bank go up to him
and ask for a photo and he said no I
think he's a rude person that's right
he's just he does it unappreciative I
think there's the word wisecrack
that's another LJ Spears in the chat
wisecrack that's another great call
right there wisecrack is a great YouTube
channel oh man there their philosophy
breakdown videos are so damn good if you
guys haven't seen wisecrack do give them
a shot oh yes again they're doing like
they do great stuff for pop culture and
just culture because they've been doing
stuff about like news and pandemics too
lately it's really interesting and fun
really yeah dad's it's true John if I'm
not talking you if you've been talking
you just keep looking at your phone I'm
sorry I apologize to you it's rude chef
blj series Nerdist alg it's rude I am
rude yeah rude boy come on ruse our mom
tells it pick it up that's right every
morning she's like get out of bed rude
boy is that why you like it when women
call you rude boy mm-hmm that's exactly
it I just want to be told what my flaws
are that's what turns me on
tell me what works or some people tell
me what habits of mine I could improve
Oh my girlfriends always like your
penises
too big it's too big it's too curved and
I'm like I can't do anything about it
I can't shave it down anymore and then
one of her other insults that she always
says to me is you always lie and tell
people you have a big penis oh you don't
oh damn either flip there ya see the
flip that I did there we lost people
watching the stream they needs a lot
don't disillusion the people I'm
discount markiplier let markiplier have
the baby alright let Greg out have the
average penis and leave the big [ __ ]
from our complexion Erik horseman thanks
again for the additional super Chetty he
also says and the normies yeah
absolutely I love those normies got to
love those normies - err normal they are
beyond normal beyond beyond the normal I
don't have anything they're not normal
at all since laters asking if we should
stop watching if they just stop watching
this and focus on writing his English
essay just keep us in the background I
think we're like good concentration
piano music you know yeah what's in the
background we hit that right frequency
that makes your brain memory things
better also there's a service that we
recently got hit up by if you want to
I'm mostly leaning because we're not
quite centered Corinne D you guys
kirinda Petra Wow
I like this new version of showing
people yes it's good because it makes
the space more fun to use Corinne
Corinne chlorine-chlorine deep lauren
dammit correct so sweet so sweetie so
sweet mmm dorkly we are not doing
another livestream on Saturday now it's
just a day honestly probably gonna take
Saturday off we're going on Ben
Bateman's
show what's it called getting Ben with
baby get invaded by bait and switch
Ben Bateman variety action action arrive
action industry action industry there
you go Ben show on Sunday so we're gonna
take Saturday off you know yeah prepare
we got a rest up for Ben oh there's a
new Parks and Recreation episode I heard
about that
just one yeah well I think that it's on
my reunion special oh that's cool hi top
films is another great one yes yes Salad
Fingers a good one who ever made salad
fingers oh mighty raccoon is also
another really great reaction Shannara
our youtube channel d avid Henry David
Henry David Henry might be in my
contacts an old number for David he
won't answer that I'm pretty sure it's
an old number yeah you probably changed
just to keep you office sense I think
we've triggered some people by saying
we're not as big a fans as cinema wins
as we are of cinemasins I much prefer
the theory I see the thing is I watch
cinemasins and I find myself like
objecting a lot more avidly yeah that's
true I always find myself wanting to
defend the movies god I'm trying to
think of what's another great you said
so many YouTube channels I mean yeah
flick big Scott covered him who else do
we watch like who do I want to name
channels that we don't react to but we
definitely watch on our own time a lot
Deadpool party has done a bunch of
reactions to our sketches and it
delights me every time he does Oh Omni
media okay YouTube channel right there
me me it is wonderful reactions mm-hmm
oh uh our boy David Waterhouse blood
David bloody fury has his own official
YouTube channel now he does like puppet
shows and different comedy sketches mmm
it's a pretty fun guy we might have to
go back to the old way of doing this to
make it easier see there
oh no this one's good Alfred threats
thank you dude hey guys what's up
brothers Oh Oh John do it in your bet
your wife
it's a doing your best black guy voice
oh yeah come on John um hey guys what's
up brothers love you guys
I'm mad that we see is just convincing
no John do your most stereotypical black
guy voice and then finally I can get you
cancelled from the channel
permanently go do it
we're losing viewers John hey guys love
you guys
I'm just gonna be Sam Jackson now I'm
mad we can't see venom 2 or Morbius
thoughts also let me shout out to me by
the way a really entertaining well thank
you by the way Alfred appreciate that
your contribution everybody I'm I'm okay
with the delays I mean as much of a
bummer as they are I think it's better
to be safe than sorry
and I want to be comfortable going back
to the theaters from the crowd full of
people I will I will not watch those on
P VOD that's who I say my stance is that
one statement there are certain movies
that won't mind watching on P VOD okay
there's some that I'm like what I have
[ __ ] watch Charles world tour in the
theaters know what I pay to watch a DVD
no but like there's one if a quiet place
to would come out on VOD would you have
watched it yeah you might you might
watch a quiet I might watch a quiet
place to I mean I would love to watch it
in the theaters that's my preference but
if a quiet place to came out in on P VOD
I'd have better control people not
making [ __ ] noise yes yeah every time
I go to a theater there's someone who's
annoying the [ __ ] out of me who's like
on their phone or talking and in a movie
oh that was so rude
there's always someone to annoy the [ __ ]
out of me in a theater and for a movie
like a quiet place to I'd wanted to I
wanted to be a really quiet theater
and if I hear someone just chewing
popcorn I'm gonna get into it I'm a hard
person to watch a movie with John about
Omaha MA I'm very upside individual had
a movie theater monitor my breathing
patterns no fairness to you breathe
really [ __ ] loud in the theater and I
keep that in mind other people have told
you that not just many years ago ah
Olivia's heard it guys I believe loud in
the theaters you know I breathe through
my mouth I breathe through my mouth and
the theaters now you show how I do I'll
tell you one thing Alfred threats in
regards to your super check question I'm
glad we're not watching Morbius together
in theaters I'm gonna have you sit two
rows apart from me okay I'll sit two
rows behind you later so be like John's
breathing here any brain joy nosed
[ __ ] John's nose big old nose all I
heard through Black Panther was this
guy's nostrils if it aint Andrew
predicting stuff it's me it's me
breathing so you have a consistent
breeding and and you have a consistent
breathing Andrew Gordon has this like
every ten minutes
oh yeah the airlock the cabin pressure
some other YouTube channels you got up
in here killing it hi hi there we go
there we go that's how you recommend
other YouTube channels you just shout
don't tell them what it's about
[Applause]
oh I don't know [ __ ] I'm gonna have to
look up AG some words to make sure I can
flash people super chats on screen
whenever I put this down we're gonna
have to kind of share Mike I mean I'm
not gonna say anything right now so I
will keep you guys entertained queen
tofu does anybody have any particularly
favorite cooking or food related
channels because there are a ton of
those I mean howtobasic is the classic
you gotta love how to basic but yeah I
don't know has anybody found anything
it's how to basic still around yes I
just watch him make a pineapple pizza
it was ooh
also Iraq Iraq agai yeah I haven't seen
them in an age you know I want to look
at this guy I don't know if he has I
don't know if he has a YouTube channel
but but I love his Olivia can't stand
him but I think he's so funny
no no I don't know if he has a YouTube
channel but follow him on Instagram his
name is Jackson Oh Doherty okay he's
like this a guy from Australia they
moved to LA recently they do these like
public prank videos that are so and like
the real though you know they're real I
don't describe it but if they're the
closest thing to supplicating
supplementing jackass alright accent or
Daugherty's really funny interesting
yeah you gotta check him out speaking of
Australians by the way I love red I love
Resident Evil I love recipe now mr.
Sunday movies I like a lot how do we
know mr. Sunday movies how do we not
mention miss or something Jimmy guys
we'll see you next week what he did with
the claymation of Rises of the Colin
Trevorrow Rises Skywalker's but that was
a brilliant idea brilliant genius I say
follow or get out
okay did we get any cooking shows in
there I don't know we didn't I guess not
Alton Brown Oh somebody's shot at Alton
Brown in the comments and I have not
been able to catch one of his live
streams but he does do one of my
favorite cooking shows on the
televisions Alton Brown yeah he used to
do a show called good eats on the Food
Network where he would basically do a
cooking show but he was like a
commercial filmmaker beforehand and he
basically started the show cuz he
thought a lot cooking shows really dry
and boring so he used his filmmaking
skills to make a more engaging cooking
show and now he's on YouTube obviously
because no one's making shows I stopped
listening about five words ago oh yeah
you had me going for it's okay it's okay
they got the last 500 startups I'm used
to people tuning out in that about span
of time well I think it's because you're
anticipating people not being interested
John so maybe if you talk with in a way
where you were you know this is not a
good example every of what I'm confident
there's probably a TED talk on this the
TED channel TED talks are great so I TED
Talks is that just the YouTube channels
or an actual show that I'm not aware of
I mean they have like their own audio
podcast and a radio show and things like
that but I don't know the origin and if
the origin was just some kind of YouTube
Anisa birthday girl
the real rejects because they're the
sweetest people ever mean and make
amazing content also just saw John is
wearing the shirt I gave him you just
saw this yeah i gestured when we gesture
thank you in this top of the street you
go you will go we'll go treat ourselves
we'll trade sure it was your birthday
money we'll go buy ourselves a cake with
your name do a livestream of us stop it
really sweet random Andy's channel huge
fan thank you dude and appreciate that
your contribution you're a huge fan of
film analysis channels so many dilemmas
and troubles child I love that gives
great hilarious commentaries the movies
I never never heard of Dylan I don't
have you know I haven't we both have to
check that out we have to yes and me
next time I haven't - yes you know the
rules of improv yes I have and he's a
great channel you should check out Dylan
and save him from the trouble I will
bookmark honest I saw a lot of times in
these live streams it's been great about
a lot of these live streams is a lot of
them are like hey tell us your favorite
something and then I'll go and actually
check out that favorite something later
on so I really appreciate that we have
to check out Dylan is in trouble here
you go oh another great one that just
popped into my head that I like a lot is
let me explain if you like you know
movie commentary channels and stuff like
that let me explain is good one he's got
a pretty good intellectual breakdown of
things but in a enjoyable poppy package
- totes had every anyone but you know I
hear the new John Krasinski YouTube
channels really fun
Oh some good news yeah do you think he
would let us react to his videos maybe I
mean you never like this is all I have a
quite a place you got pushback on yeah
he already makes you know jokes about
stealing content on his own show so I
think we'd be just no one's watching the
Jack Ryan show it's pretty engaging Oh
Eric horsemen and Koreans its fury on
Eric has the funniest taste in stuff
Thank You Ariel Eric Eric recommend some
great stuff though you he's got a wide
palette I do have to give Eric that for
sure one time on patreon
Eric recommended a Nine Inch Nails video
that involved a lot of mutilation
opposed being put into a meat grinder
and a lot of penis exposure and I was
like I thought we were watching a music
video
BDSM performance artists oh yeah that
was really shocking stuff not gonna lie
good ooh who else do we got here late to
the party
Vibram not late to the party you got
some love guys invites to the parties
getting a lot of love
hey Nixon necks is that Nicky is is that
Nicky Novak or is that a different Nixon
ex
do we miss car theaters now we don't
yeah that's like I do in the Sun a lot
of ways actually I do yeah but without
movies - go - that's fair you know like
I yeah you know guys because we're
falling behind if we're gonna do this
the old-school way
Sharon that's crazy sharing the screen
and the weirdest-looking format possible
all right who are we behind on here
behind on good I am got a car in hey
guys brothers sister in there we go cat
Kyle quarters ah--this kyle cores actus
all right hi one of my Foreman on my
favorite my favorite YouTube channels
but Kyle I mean appreciate you
contributing here buddy but who is your
favorite YouTube channel and I swear to
God if you say gob Kawai I am blocking
you we'll wait and then I'm gonna
unblock you something tells me you and
your brother have have some kind of
rivalry going on no no there's a lot of
blind wave love in this chat mm-hmm you
know what guys if you don't play with so
much much you watch their low waves up
doing one right that's right blind wave
shade that's right we gotta we can't
extend that olive branch but arm down
now they're [ __ ] great though is such
a huge crew they are they are like six
people what's funny about their like the
way how we're in this little stream in
this little box right here that's like
how big their video is oh yeah or any
friend Thank You Kyle Jimmy freckles
thank you so much dude have you seen
Alton Brown get drunk with his wife
during pandemic classic stuff they say
no scrubs the other day love y'all lates
at the party as well when it comes to
movie
etc hahaha I've not seen Alton Brown get
drunk but that does sound like a really
fun time I want to I love Alton Brown
they say no scrubs the other day okay
you know who's Alton Brown Alton Brown
is that guy who you disowned out while I
was talking about he's the guy who used
to be like a commercial director and he
thought oh man these cooking shows are
really dry I'll make my own that's like
a lot more visually engaging and also
kind of scientific as well as cooking
and now he does all bunch of stuff he's
great though I'm sure whatever he's all
dad he's a lot really rewarding it was
after them lives have been changed in
the chat today go pull up in Alton Brown
and learn how to make the perfect
hard-boiled egg you know what John I
decided from here on out I'm gonna be
overly complimentary to you thank you
that's gonna throw me off much more I'm
gonna be like way too kind you okay
okay see how that works go [ __ ] yourself
that was a last thing I need to get on
my chest yeah I think you're doing now
right and one day there'll be a time
we're all not in these streams and
there'll be way more people watching
when I'm not in it because only you by
yourself I am that your own good you are
I am NOT hearing sarcasm I'm not being
sarcastic John I know you're not you're
the best human being
oh that's true I've ever met I thank you
for the affirmation and I find your
breathing in the movie theater oh yeah
soothing truly it's it helps me sleep
that's why I do it so well if I could do
a recording of your breathing and the
movie theatres it could be what do
people call that way like when white
noise yeah white noise it's like white
noise I'll just refer you attend our
super reduce white noise I am putting
that I say Mila you know white noise to
was supposed to be all right
with Nathan Fillion hey John do you mind
if I transition to chase Gardner's
superchip biochemicals thank you is
Jimmy freckles your Jimmy no hey Jimmy
freckles hey shut me Flemmi freckles
hey go why don't you go whack blushy
bill chase gardener Thank You chase for
you're super chat buddy the retro replay
channel just plays video games the voice
actor behind Nathan Drake ooh Odin Nolan
North and Uncharted games runs the
channel really damn that sounds like a
really good chance a was that once
that's how you pitch a [ __ ] channel
Thank You chase Gardner yeah
retro replay channel let me subscribe to
them right it's gotta be good the guy
behind the uncharted is doing it John
John let me help you fill the void here
mm-hmm who would you cast to play Nathan
Drake who would I cast to play Nathan
Drake I would cast Misha Collins just
subscribed to the retro replay channel
people just subscribe see you guys can
see right there boom I would cast Robbie
a mill in a bunch of straight-to-video
scooby-doo movies as friends yeah he's
my Nathan Drake who's your Nathan Drake
you know I think Stephen Amell would
actually be a decent Nathan Drake
probably what he's got the like voyage
just like that a bunch of dislike his
dog brown hair enough he's too blond I
think you'd be better than Tom Holland
I'm just saying well thank you chase
Gardner
Anisa again right here I don't know if
you guys can see this la snobby channel
what's sabi Channel I'm thinking about
getting a real GTX that's it so hey John
what's up want to get some coffee
sometime or pump my gas for me wow I
think she escalated I think she wants
you to pump some gas into her John I'll
meet you at the gas station with a
coffee John just tell her you want a
pumper I will pump your gas Oh telling
me so you're full-service it's all
service it's her birthday tell her your
pump your tank and pump you a car full
of
yeah guzzoline that's exactly what I'm
trying to write with all these innocuous
auto mechanic talks to the subscribers
like that no I want to be canceled was
getting caught part of your plan
yes I want to destroy the feminist
movement from the inside Anissa don't
get a real rejects that too you should
get a John tattoo yes just of my face
I appreciate you'll never live to regret
it I appreciate the consideration though
on getting one of those mm-hmm mm-hmm Oh
more Tyrone Magnus love was a lot of
Tyrone Magnus love in here too much
Tyrone Mac she didn't text me back last
time
a vote for oh dude we gotta call him a
Tyrone III don't think likes texting
because I every time I text Jairo Magnus
he always sends me back on a voice
message which I'm always happy to hear
his voice message Tyrone's voice yeah
you have to pay for that but I always
text him I never send him a voice
message pad okay it's always a voice
message though
maybe I nothing a trailer so yeah this
message will delete itself after two
minutes they can't find me I don't know
where Tyrone try on Magnus how do you
watch back these live streams how do you
watch this back you got the screen of us
here then you got this little small
screen and the super chest there or
there's a weird [ __ ] background going
on and then us and even smaller parts
I can probably kill the weird background
if that would make how do you do that oh
let's see let's see if I remember just
go that so much better no no no no I
will do this alright yeah there you go
oh that's nice it's much nicer no no
killer let's just settle on this image
for a little bit this is the new
thumbnail of the video gaming channels
would be basically I do work smiley with
a seven Jeff and Korey kenshin
non-gaming would be good
Lync shauncy John you enjoy the shiny
one yeah new rock stars
Schatzi more than Edel drop i can see
that that's like hey he's great too
alright there we go
we both got saying that's fair I'm just
saying you prefer the white guy I am a
racist but but I'm gonna one-up you one
better with racism and say that no I'm
not gonna but deadhead and hip-hop is a
good channel to new rock stars and you
guys and you guys sure I could think of
more but once I thought of you guys I
decided to end it there well thanks PJ
Brad we got some of them to come and I
don't know these other guys
oh but PJ you you're the PJ with the
lovely avatar love you buddy
love you buddy thank you thank you for
your love don't worry guys we're gonna
switch the stream labs for next time and
it's gonna is this menu thing is gonna
look so much better I think I don't know
I don't know if stream weather but I
think it's possible it might look much
better
Erica Tuesday in the chat what's up
corridor crew some more high tech films
we got some love for Eminem's channel
there's a lot of venom in your epic
voice guys here we're not two hours
behind here epic voice guy I just
accidentally scroll to the very bottom
of the list
oh yeah so I roll who else is in here
well Thank You PJ those are great very
and you watch more gaming channels yeah
you do
what's up with that what are you doing
that's a great YouTube channel idea
what's up with that that we just talked
about topics where every video goes what
something what's up with that what's up
with that I want to shout out and then
we if you guys want to get all the Amber
Heard Johnny Depp updates about the guy
with the the wonderful southern accent
no not him
the Johnny Depp follows this guy on
Instagram incredibly average okay
is his YouTube channel with only thirty
five thousand subscribers currently
averages like 300,000 views a video ring
the Johnny Depp amber as well oh look at
that oh if you go to his channel it's
all the
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard audios and
reports and but he I want to shout him
out to keep updated on that all right
yeah he follow Johnny Depp follows
barely anybody on his Instagram this
little YouTube channel
he follows he's sticking up for me that
was my you Johnny when I first looked at
my Instagram when I first looked at my
Instagram when I saw his Instagram video
is the first one he did I was like this
is exactly how I thought of Johnny Depp
Instagram video follow join up on its
channel use the following he could you
just re upload that guy's videos who is
releasing all the Amber Heard video yeah
I just sponsor that guy's channel Olivia
I eat that [ __ ] up we love those audios
none of the right you know what [ __ ] it
yeah I'm gonna say it we love them
because we love it's not something to
say you love because they're technically
like really horrible anguish uneasy cuz
there's no reason they get a lot of
views people love them but we love
justice for Johnny justice for John who
ever got mad at me that one time when I
was like said something about Johnny
Depp on Twitter and they're like you
never read the case documents I'm like
who's read the case documents and now
everyone has the case documents now I'm
like ah [ __ ] I should take a lot of back
go through your old tweets now before
somebody finds out you had a different
opinion of mine before you got new info
now I'm much more careful where I state
my opinions yeah Mel Gibson's I can't
wait for amber her to return in Aquaman
to Shu level TV thank you dude favorites
Smosh mega Haga
paired up ha real rejects etc dude dude
I know we're on the top of the list
there between those other movie alright
I know nigahiga a little bit
like personally no a wish see how I said
it because I was worried that it would
sound like some saying something else I
put it what a slang
I then Smosh nigahiga yeah yeah yeah
because I was like I don't want to have
you don't smart like that it's called
brain power I once saw a compilation of
this is very specific it was like
misheard lyrics and k-pops that sound
like racism and it was a rabbit hole I
tell you what you know what it's not a
YouTube channel but I do just adore
YouTube poops of like king of them know
and stuff like that you know there's a
lot of people in here saying damn
murrells new channel is really great and
it is it is he when he left screen
junkies he was prepared mm-hmm as much
as he's like doing videos and a lot of
times like I'm still figuring this out
I'm tinkering with this like dude your
shits like [ __ ] incredible it's a
really good big yeah it's really good
channel will watch your success Niraj is
right we were supposed to order pizza in
the /aa let's go back to the Super chats
here again let's go back to the
beginning of the stream going back to
going through all these comments vertigo
is a hit in Aussie Jim yam splaining
what does that mean me and sounds cool
Rizzo gaming Ryan matey
Dorothy Oda zero six six real rejects
blind wave sidemen jacksepticeye una
Rose and Rosie Jeremy Johnson Amanda
wins love you guys having a 2 a.m. drink
for this oh but thanks for being here
dear maybe we can start we should we
should start live streaming I like 1
a.m.
mm-hmm so that all the UK people get it
in the afternoon a real rejection live
cheerio to the real region it's reached
that point in the hour is upon and then
25 minutes from now it's the tire trying
to keep the energy up oh yeah ok Ice and
Fire
why oh wait why mhm what's why I'm aged
I thought you meant your
movie sucked wait a second we did it
miss Carter Lovejoy's did we miss mr.
Carter Christopher stuckman we talked
about the last two weeks we talked about
it Karger we didn't miss you less
YouTube is screwing this one up all
right or unless we haven't gone well
Thank You Ryan Beatty do get some sleep
please well we gonna watch our Doctor
Who reaction on Sunday hmm that's why
you need to sleep now
on Thursday again there Nawroz Carson on
Nick be a toe is another YouTube channel
I like and Rick be a toe well thank you
to you for your super chat there and
buddy all right what do you say Nick be
a toe I'm the you know whoever Niraj
recommend can I subscribe that's just
the way I work with Niraj man mm-hmm it
pretty much informs our taste yeah this
is really I know this hey we are
subscribed to him hey oh yeah I think
John found this guy yeah I think
probably I was probably trying to learn
some know what let's do that all right
there you go Nick mm-hmm and Rick Rick
Thank You Nicholas that guy Kerry that's
John Kerry who John Kerry mm-hmm
he was a great president he so it was Al
Gore yeah
loved him cinemasins react channel react
channel ism I love react channel of
react channel
I love it game theorists good channel
the gorgeous hunks the real rejects whoa
thanks man and I love the Simon as well
well that guy Kerry I think these are
all really good channels game dear oh my
god game theory and film theory also
exceptional channels net matpat at dan
and Alyssa's wedding very very sexist
really really he is as nice and chipper
as you would expect in real life and
into Broadway we talked about Broadway
thank you guys for being here that guy
can love your love your profile pic
right here to Erika Tuesday what's up
Eric up babe more like Erika please let
me say like
she said more like Erica Thursday $75 I
shouldn't do that
yeah every sound person in this feeds
butthole did that
happy Thursday to you Erica hope your
token up for us right now
and by token I mean snorting crash oh
yeah cuz it's 4:30 snort crack 30 hours
we should be a drug holiday for every
year something like a holiday for every
drug dude this is heroin why is no one
we're doing this this whole time
guys you drop the bomb dropping the ball
international mushrooms they do that
today everyone stayed indoors saw some
things people made attempts to shave
their eyeballs oh man I want to try
mushrooms
one day I'll try shrooms mm-hm one day
well you know what's the Italian
restaurants open back up alright so what
are people saying in the in the chat
right here got some jontron love over
here [ __ ] tool and raid wolf gamer does
she XP Aldo Jones oh my god thank you
for mentioning Aldo Jones is he still
making videos lately I think I haven't
seen a big one we have the notification
set up for Aldo Jones he's like a couple
weeks last time we did a video was a
month ago only damn I'm glad glad it was
bully Maguire I should unpledged from
his patreon yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] man
God Aldo Jones
where's my free content that I pay a
nominal fee as ganja they get Z monetize
all the time Aldo God I still remember
watching Aldo Jones's
first BVS weird trailer I think those is
first like big video God watching those
tropes grow of like Batman's newspaper
and bully Maguire and all that stuff I
watched that with Breanna white you guys
from watched that reaction on YouTube
obviously i watch so Breanna white I
believed I was incredibly high you're
the fun thing to do but behind the
scenes on YouTube when you talk to other
YouTube creators and I was watching this
interview of Bruce camel on a ready to
interview the other day where he talked
about how there were some scenes in evil
did that they filmed hi is when you meet
other youtubers who smoke weed and you
try to find out which videos they did
that they were not everyone most of them
declare or say I'm high you know but
therefore there's some videos that well
I could be [ __ ] up because obviously
they didn't mention it for a reason
they were waiting for you okay uh force
Evans is Nathan Drake I think he's I
think he is beyond those roles right now
Chris Evans yeah Chris Evans would be a
great Nathan drink I just don't think I
don't want to see him do the smaller
films John I don't give a [ __ ] about his
Apple TV [ __ ] Captain America go back to
Captain America or playing douchebags in
movies like knives out two modes the
best guy a little worse yeah seriously
you ever see him play Captain America or
play way against captain that's how I be
way it's entertaining it's white people
for you I'm surprised no one's mentioned
Philly D philip defranco you're
beautiful comes works to say unless you
go racist and I'm not gonna do that
John we'll just go racist when we're not
live it's my go-to joke when Murray I
love ya Kyle core I hope people are
smart if you're tuning in right now
who's your first time tuning in to the
live stream you came at the right time
ten hour and a half in is the right time
this is when Greg and John are or we're
taking it easy Caio Kosar it is is
saying I wanted to take a quick moment
to promote the mixed 3 we have
interviews of MMA fighters artists who
drinks reviews and so much more part 1
well well the mix 3 get ready for this
it's time look out oh my god how
confusing with this be if we just kept
another live oh yeah mixed 3 right this
would be saying this guy well there we
go there you go mix 3 just got yourself
a subscriber
mmm-hmm so your your you owe us now well
thank you mixer e4 contributes to the
super chat and I hope that your
interviews of MMA fighters continues to
go well out there and I hope none of
them ever put you in a chokehold buddy
on funny enough our buddy Tony used to
shoot MMA fights
does he still he also used to shoot
people I did he did that's a dark joke
don't go down and stopped
oh you know what I also do want to
mention quarter crew has her other
channel that's not as popular but it's
still amazing corridor digital go check
that channel out and the corner crew
team is very nice we met them at the
screening for not I am Legend Oh Gemini
man Gemini man it's good for Gemini man
and they were like half of them the
bottom oh oh no we met half of them but
they were there really it's always
refreshing when you meet people who you
are genuinely admire you know that
phrasing they say told me you're gross I
honestly haven't had that experience
where my [ __ ] phrase is so true yeah
and I haven't had that experience
everyone I've ever been a fan of that
I've been fortunate enough to meet in
person whether it be film TV music met
Beyonce like five times a huge Beyonce
fan
you know jay-z Destiny's Child such good
say my name my god such a big survivor I
really I'm really up to date with all
the new be on same track although we
also saw daddy lessons with the lemonade
hey Queen B she's tuning in right now
I'm watching this dream yeah jenna
Marbles is also an all-time favorite
yes jenna Marbles you know she's great
she was the first how to boyfriend does
my makeup video that I've ever watched
and then I was like oh this is Jennifer
videos I don't know I haven't heard her
name in a minute but I think she does
she may be uh on the cameo app or
something like maybe that was the last
place I saw jenna Marbles
oh wow no she's still doing pretty well
mill my god she is still killing he's
still killing the game well that solved
that oh I love her new hairdo well there
you go you're gonna have to get an
undercut now let's go to her hair I'm
sure you go to channels oh damn oh the
hair this is great stuff right this is
this is a reaction this is how I watch
real reactions this is how I really
didn't do it undercut it oh no what man
both the [ __ ] and that other image you
had their hair there that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's an edited thumbnail but thank you a
Nisa thank you for contributing to the
chat here I want some logan paul love
all right Logan glad I'm glad he
deserves a comeback it's time you know
who I'm seeing this start with logan
paul and then ECOMOG oh yeah stromal
nation go watch their channel nation
struggle nation mentioned that he was
hanging out with her
and then I saw her on Logan Paul's
channel and then I see her on Rocco
Rocco a lot and now I see her on
on Jackson Oh Doherty I see her like on
all these like YouTube things now the
porn star what's her name
[ __ ] Reid chick Riley Riley Riley
Reid yeah I'm sure Singh
he said Logan Paul I remember the last
watch Riley Reed was in it which put me
down that path of like I'm seeing that
porn star Riley read and all these like
in youtuber videos now it's a brave new
world filled with all kinds of media
across kampala nation that's a
combination of words like I didn't know
the name I knew it was I knew it
instantly yeah it only makes you look
like a wonderful actress one watt mono
flashes yeah mm-hmm Josh a great two
sasha grey is a okay know who I saw
recently I saw ron jeremy really as i
ron jeremy walking into a coffee shop in
Burbank oh and he was he got out of like
a like a like a town car with like four
other people one of whom was a child and
like it was a nice car it looked like
they were out for like a nice Sunday
afternoon except he was in his same like
ball shorts and tank top that I saw him
in the airport wearing so uh ron jeremy
still alive and well during quarantine
ron jeremy man is here it's over like
four thousand women oh it's got to be
something silly odd silly ridiculous
like that Josh Peck has a YouTube
channel
what nerd war nice the season
you're gonna activate that guy and there
you go all right we're back we're done
we're not answering any more Super Why
mhm yeah we're done no one's copy thanks
for contributing in vain there is a lot
of Chris Evans is Nathan Drake in here
we're doing John Bailey John Bailey does
not get enough love from his children
John Bailey does not get enough love and
there's children love miss children are
great in the YouTube sphere man because
John Bailey is one of the most generous
kind and he is also one of the people
who will like drop things to go help you
out he is that that kind of individual I
love that man love you John Bailey also
he has the best answering machine like
his voicemail on his cell phone I just
heard it for the first time yesterday so
good guys I'm gonna give you guys John
Bailey's phone number why is everyone
saying milk I'm Harvey Milk and I'm
going to recruit you know why why is
everyone saying milk I don't I don't get
it I have no clue Jake Paul yeah no what
is smell what is this milk thing is milk
a channel no that's what they're all
spamming with the word milk milk is
better than God but what does milk mean
I don't know I don't know you know
there's another great channel hyper RPG
RPG hyper RPG is a great channel mm-hmm
those guys are really nice yeah
I saw a couple people mention hyper RPG
in the chat every time I see your fight
I'm I see your face I feel better so
thank you for your smile wait a minute
what time it's seven twelve seven oh six
pm oh that's funny I thought I like law
of attraction did I thought I was like I
said hyper RPG thing
then Adam heard Craig Corrigan door
light all like the fire that's farting
oh dude well welcome to the chat give us
any tips if you have them why is
everyone saying milk yeah can somebody
explain the mole on I'm gonna go find
Olivia to see if she knows of those milk
things all about well well well yeah we
talking dairy milk here we talking
Francis what is it with all these weird
director hot takes because honestly I
want Spike Jonze Spike Lee somebody say
Spike Lee fourth or five or Spike Jonze
because I would want a collab
co-directing Francis Ford Coppola for
Fantastic Four I don't know man was
twixt any good I went up to Olivia and I
said people are spamming the word milk
on our live stream and she's like milk
like yeah what does that mean she goes
it's a beverage and if you shut the door
that that was helpful
what the [ __ ] does the milk thing mean
looking somebody enlighten us before
Francis Ford Coppola gets the job this
is literally the most composed film but
he pitched Morbius Spike Lee fourth or
five or Spike Jonze I can't remember
which and like there are bunch of weird
director pitches going on right now
along with the milk so how do I just
show this this on screen doors click
that click the left one what yeah this
one is that oh that's so cool look at
that guys look at that we're figuring
out how to do this in real time don't
worry I got this
oh I mean what if I just wanted to show
this one okay that guy's Travis Austin
thank you so much dude
happy Thursday boys happy Thursday boys
booze and blood stirring space Orchestra
koku what the [ __ ] Peru William belly
not oh you tubers it's a theme I would
assume thank you for your very kind very
kind super chatter Austin yeah I love
Travis Austin my god boys booze and
blood what the hell is that and channel
stuff or is the challenge called boys
and there's another channel called booze
and another one called blood or maybe
just those three concepts in life
guys it's jenna Marbles dude jenna
Marbles is her her success is rubbing
off on this live stream oh you know what
youtuber I love but one that spit on her
dog oh what a great youtuber she's still
making videos let's find out let's get
her on the chat let's have hurt oh they
do you like music
I think so that's cool with the podcast
guys who's that youtuber who spit on her
dog horrible individually yeah yeah
aggressive comics is good though I like
aggressive calm aggressive comics is a
good one
David Fincher for the Punisher I could
see that
Travis Austin thank you so much dude I
really appreciate it are you from Austin
I hear Texas is opening up restaurants
sorry to hear that and you stay sexy oh
my god Erick horsemen my guy and teeth
guess again who are those guys alright
let's just little copy and paste here
I'll copy and paste learning what you
guys love and what you guys distaste no
it's another reaction channel Wow
stepping on our turf era course Wow what
does cease Kisei anyway yeah she looks
cool alright alright Eric since
- I'm gonna subscribe and she's cool I'm
gonna subscribe what if I well if I just
unsubscribe right here on the street to
prove that were liars
I should just go to a whole bunch of
YouTube channels just unsubscribe them
right here Chris stock man's got all
these popular ones Thank You Aaron crew
all your favorite very contributing to
the Super chats Thank You Travis
Austin Carter Lovejoy's back in the game
again one I like a lot is Bryan hull
such a sweet guy Carter you have
contributed so much super chats see guys
your contributions are going to get
these guys more subscribe this is a
charity livestream and we're giving away
subscriptions well obviously I mean I
like doing it this way in terms of
subscribing because a lot of times
people recommend someone to me and you
know I'll say like yeah I'll check them
out but I don't yeah so when I subscribe
they eventually they'll pop up in my
feed and then I'll go let me check this
out now and then I do and in there also
oh I know Bryan all I've seen this
videos before but I haven't subscribed
yet and you haven't unsubscribed yes
thanks buddy
Oh Kyle's back I Oh Isis Kyle thank you
dude I subscribed I subscribed right
here during the stream I subscribed
directly to it buddy
your subscriptions and you'll see our
avatar guys what is this milk thing
what is this milk thing baby I am sorry
gonna get me Baskin Robbins - I want to
I have never seen Todd for the Howard
the Duck yes we need the gritty take the
animal abuse allegory of Howard the Duck
wait wait who did we not subscribe to
what I don't know Jayden what jail in
Westbrook who do we I don't know Joe
no Jerri sorted out chaos over here
sorted out for us you know whose Trin
Lavelle I've never heard Trin Lavelle
Martin Scorsese for Avengers 5 that is
gonna be one
Olivia loves get Jabby that's nice
all right guys whoa oh look where we are
now
all Jabby coy hey I'm live-streaming
right now okay but Gabby kuai we don't
know how to properly work our windows on
this format so it just looks like utter
chaos over yeah no no we paused it
you're not lighter on Lord you're on
speaker don't screw this up because you
could get sub guys subscribe to jabbing
Kawai I just want you to know we've lost
15 viewers oh and since I got on the
phone with you man man endure King says
hi to the abbey people are significantly
less interested now that you're here
subscribe subscribe to a charg is
subscribed to a charas channel crossover
times is crocheted this is how we cross
over on the real regions call people on
the phone what's it like over there you
got to show me your live streaming
program because we're not figuring this
out
well milk you think we'll know how to
use OBS John figured OBS I've figured
out some of OBS I did in art because of
recent things I'd have a bit alright
I'll let you go please continue to watch
the live stream and if you want to
contribute $100 an American USD to the
live stream that would be great yes with
my brother my brother $7,500 little
helps to know okay great do you want ice
cream I think Olivia's asking alright
thank you thank you thank you brother
javi cool a I'm gonna let you go down
what shallow I don't want to be shallow
Tommy wise ocean definitely my brother
only said I said I
of you on speakerphone because he was on
speakerphone I've never presented time
he's not gonna say I love you it's very
good by James Franco for spider-man
before to direct it like the disaster
artist who knows man let's see who else
we got here we got a super chat from
Erica and now it's John I control the
mouse why are we always so behind
oh my God look at his profile pic look
at that wonder he does so much better
than a lovely drawing of you I say at
98% of 89% the time he's downsizing
himself all right yeah yeah yeah we got
to get OBS Erica one of my favorite
channels is the School of Life the
infographics show and today I found out
are also great I don't know the
infographics show or today I found out
I'll tell you hey you gonna go I just
texted you oh here you go
you you you wallet your clothes and your
motorcycle give them to me so yeah I
would say which one she say Thank You
Erica by the way school of life as well
as the infograph can't wait to go back
to the jacuzzi with you yeah and today I
found out check out some of these guys
all right school of life's great so guys
in the chat guys in the chat Erica right
now is recommending one of my favorite
channels of school life the infographic
show and today I found out are also
great which one should we subscribe to
right here on this chat which one and
we'll follow you we should subscribe to
the milk channel yes we should got milk
of course the cat wants back out this
cat is always wanting to get inside only
really close then yeah you know I've sat
at the windowsill for like an hour now I
go ooh bully Maguire as Avengers five
villain that's my dream
alright lag I don't know is there lag
of course there's lag today I found out
might be fun for us then it is decided
okay today I found out because we
already subscribe to the school of John
type it in today I found out that
subscribe button
oh yeah 2.26 more feed is gonna be so
cool so many new channels to check out
get ready for some very different
reactions you could always count on my
brother Jabby too if there's a slight
technical thing he's going to correct it
right away thanks for doing that man can
you just be on standby for everyone case
we need tech support someone's asking
what does your cat do in the house all
day with quarantine before lay around
not stuff down try to find food eat
sleep repeat all right so we got Thank
You Erica appreciate your contribution
again so way too sweet to us Erica can't
wait to go back in your jacuzzi Patrick
Patrick's back in here Pat our favorite
channels Campea Magnus cosmic wonder
everything always real rejects and I'm
Portuguese from earlier post Oh John
John shout out Peter Pacheco in your
best Portuguese voice go Pacheco
thanks for coming third Channel I don't
know what accent I'm trying to do
because that I know they're little but
the Portuguese like I breathe is very
rare as I brought you on this channel
will fulfill what I could not do and one
of them was a bunch of you're supposed
to be the Fred Armisen I just I just
watch this video about all the North
American accent yes it was I know oh I
know I have no frame of reference for a
they're getting shown on screen that is
the way hey if you super chat I will
gladly respond to John my god you gotta
get better on
it was in the eastern here of getting
look at the hey you're getting no let's
see your social blade it's on it's now
integrated into our YouTube as a widget
social blade is so funny their numbers
are crazy now they'll be like the other
make somewhere between $300 to $150,000
a month yeah every possible range is in
course or you got one so you got someone
here defending you thank you
trademark let's go back to here and go
back Oh Brittany you haven't you changed
your Britney Lee changed her profile pic
again back to your to your daughter
nice the photo was taken in victoria bic
british columbia the photo was taken in
victoria before Christ it's an amazing
place to go this photo was taken by the
Empress Hotel by then Inner Harbor
Victoria go on Google and take a look
it's great isn't the what's the haute
Empress Hotel famous for isn't it famous
for something I believe the Empress
Hotel was famous for conquering the the
Mongols yes and with the heading their
leader with fantastic amenities in room
sir yes what's one giant John look you
got a shout out Britney Lange in your
best Canadian accent do it well oh hey
Britney a I hope you're enjoying some
smokes and a good Tim Hortons we love
you and say hi to your daughter for us
cool and if anybody catches that
reference you're my buddy Shane your
homegirl good guy I'm going on your
impressions are letting feeling out I
have an accent cassette tape an accent
CD and whichever one is Portuguese I'm
popping in and I'm say buddy
I'll by Jaylon I'm so sorry that we
didn't subscribe to something see you
buddy
I hope that you're coming back at some
point he would not
NIC's and next guys go check out her
YouTube channel she is such a sweetheart
such a sweet yeah you love it you want
an Aussie accent is that it you know
many uh all the venom tryla the venom
trail is out now I hear that's not what
I heard
no she asked for all the excess yes for
Australia you should see if blind wave
needs an extra member they they have a
guy who looks like me already people
often think I'm him well he can now take
a break you could set it and they won't
even notice the difference cameras are
always so far away because there's like
18 people on their set mm-hmm I'm just
growing my beard out that's all give it
a week or two and I'll be there
Thank You Brittany all right John
aneesa's back
give me another accent I can't do shout
out Aneesa super chat here in your best
Texas accent thank you and you suffer
this super chat by the way yeah I was
kid of brought donuts on my birthday to
make friends yeah I was huge fan oh wait
yeah I was a pretty lonely kid alright
alright alright
Matthew McConaughey's from Alabama he's
from Texas is 100% from Alabama watch I
was that kid who brought Donuts to my
class I tell you what when I type in
right here where's Matthew Han let me
show you guys just fullscreen Kilgore
Texas where's Matthew McConaughey from
it's gonna say Arkansas boom oh it's
it's folded yeah my bad what you're
talking about
clearly not I'm so sorry for the non
Texan they're all Space Jam 2 I did see
the new logo
it's a logo what there's a new Space Jam
logo yeah LeBron just debut the Hat come
on man it's called John type it in Space
Jam 2 and the movie even has a subtitle
that I have since forgotten it's like a
new legend or something
you
my god God do you know how to there we
go see let's just do an image Space Jam
new legacy and there's the Hat there
King James right there you know I hope
this one is really deep and
thought-provoking yes it's gonna be you
know cuz he's gonna be away from his
family for so long
yeah you know guys I understood that
might be a lot more exciting that was
the kind of a it will download that PMG
for a thumbnail someday oh man Space Jam
2 latte
I like that Michael Burnett Oh Justin
sudden one of our patrons alright i'll
Sean chat him out in your best New
Yorker accent real rejects double toasty
you guys need the collab what's the
matter with you cinemasins and red
letter media cinemasins cinemassacre and
let red letter media huge fan of those
guys oh thank thank thank thank thank
you whoo thank you just said it had a
remix Justin Sutton Ken he wanted a
shout-out not long ago so Justin stood
out in Sutton great human being gentle
to regrip when we were young John and I
knew a kid named Justin Karen knew you
then one day I was smoking hookah at a
hookah bar and he ended up being my
waiter I was like I'm sorry
the wha are you Justin Karen Newton he's
like yeah and then I followed him on
Instagram personal trainer as well
hot-ass girlfriend guys doing all right
I got a follow now gotta hit him up
Justin said I'm just saying you gotta be
as good as that Justin that's what I'm
saying Justin something Justin was cool
man you got got big shoes to fill and
Justin had a cool dad Jim was a cool guy
you know we never Justin in regards to
your super chat we never had a facial
collab with double toasted but we did
have beers with them after they beat us
in the movie trivia Schmoe
right we went to Barney's Beanery and I
also they said cinemassacre whose feel
like we've said no we've seen
cinemassacre now we're subscribe to that
oh yeah oh yeah yeah is that is that
Doug Walker
I don't know or is that the no that's
the angry not on our door we're angry
video game nerd oh yeah I've seen
cinematic yeah according to Joe get
Jabby hold on a second get Jabby is
breaking news right here he says that
apparently our DJ is the new Wolverine
is spreading missive fake news he's in
the chat fake news and just so you guys
know Oscar I'm gonna be getting a PS 5
I'm Way more of a PlayStation gamer than
I am an Xbox person always have been
when you get PS 5 can I have ps4 no no
you don't get my stuff
fine ok shriek Sharma whoa thanks dude
you know that's actually equates to 550
Katrine thank you buddy as I understand
Kartik I'm saying a treat
Thank You Kartik that really means a lot
old favourite community channel you may
like to Shar little Indian jet project
geography now bébé Wow Wow ok you know
what I'm gonna screenshot this comment
cuz that's a lot to get involved in and
I want to do that and was because one
day I will be the top reigning Indian
reaction channel and I'll do my brother
Jabbok away
hey and apparently he Karthik was
introduced to javi through the real
rejects really yeah read then jump the
comment I was introduced to Jabbok away
by real rejects oh he's still in the
Chad that you still make Chad get a be
getting that's the reason you're at a
million subscribers because of us
introducing yo ass look out
so uh let's get a cuddle
[Laughter]
ooh I like this wait where did it go
damn but thank you Karthik oh my god oh
yes how could we forget
javi thank you FEM fail tail can't
believe I forgot Supernatural
conventions I just realized you can't
read that because of because of the hold
on a second guys
hold on hold on get down I can't believe
I forgot Supernatural conventions if you
guys are supernatural fans I'm talking
about the show you're gonna want to go
over to supernatural conventions and we
have a reaction going up to the latest
video this Saturday and we were laughing
our asses off was so [ __ ] funny so
funny most I have busted a gut in some
time yeah any busting a nut John if your
mom is watched true comedy I want his
weird-ass mom to know you busted a nut
and I had to edit out of the video it
was a major inconvenience have you
busting nuts but that's a great reaction
like that's a reaction if ever there was
one
think of that the jizz in my pants great
reaction not a bad point there so next
time you'll be thanked all right Aneesa
is tipping us again for her birth Nisa
why would I tell you about slowing down
here my god pace yourself
what'd she say did you all hear but the
news about the Hercules remake coming
soon directed by the Russo brothers what
y'all saw sure I'm a pro thank you and
Issa uh no I did not hear anything about
this hold on a second hold on are all of
the gods going to make an appearance or
is it going to be a Hercules solo hold
on a second hold on hold on
Brandon Rogers I keep seeing that name
you see here
is there really a channel about a guy
who just eats an onion until Shrek
fights ah the Russo brothers are
producing in you know and he said that
was a very misleading concept yes I
thought it was going to bring together
all of
the geology cinematic universe what
religion their Greek how they I guess
there is Greek Orthodox Christianity so
so it makes some sense yes
Coen brothers for thank you an ISA
either way I appreciate it
that's good to know mmm-hmm now we can
do a whole video about it and speculate
oh yeah what take that they'll do this
is one of those Disney as are they doing
it circa Disney is it a real live action
remake of Disney's Hercules or is it
just another Hercules well I think it's
and I think it's known of course it's a
live-action - this / - what a [ __ ] else
you think they're just gonna take 20th
century banner it's gonna be alive it's
gonna be a live action the Disney one
can't wait to see CGI Hades hair um but
that Hercules underrated I love that
film I haven't seen it since I saw it in
theaters I should revisit do [ __ ]
James Woods and Danny DeVito and whoever
played her oh thank you thank you for
for for both of you bringing me ice
cream thank you
post mated what did you get some
chocolate fudge - it's an unboxing video
now non-dairy what's good with fudge
just get a flavor reaction what's it
gonna be oh wow I can hear it crunching
you're too [ __ ] close here is this
better give me a copper now you're a
good man thank you anyway
Thank You Olivia alright she's watching
the Ruto right now you guys think we
should watching the route oh it is a
wildly popular show but we'll never
finish
maybe how many episode is it pretty long
isn't it still going why don't we just
start in a root oh right now I'm sure
won't get blocked on the stream why
can't I watch the root oh I can watch
the roots out with you but you're like
you've seen it you know I'm sick of you
controlling my life Olivia what do you
mean we're not having sex tonight you
and I have to deal with every day in
this office but this house my only
motivation stay away next life is so
strange
it's our stakes for every conflict you
just got awkward behind the scenes oh
man where do you get off nowhere tonight
oh man we are we are doing well hey cop
oh oh that was ASMR is underrated I
understand the appeal of ASMR I'm just
gonna go out on a limb and say that this
is really good is non-dairy chocolate
fudge awesome I share your enthusiasm
even finisher for Hobbes and shot two
would be a pretty interesting way to do
that it would you know sure why not get
a really dark get a really really
obsession based heavy sobs and saucy so
is this thing with about milk is that
about the movie milk
Joaquin Phoenix wanting us not to use
you know animal products I'm not anymore
all right Oh car chicks back here
WatchMojo okay hoo let me give you a
full screen here buddy watch mojo what
culture full-fat videos that take the
film theorists I know all those but
full-fat videos I'm by the way thank you
for contributing dude we're gonna
subscribe to full fat video
what's full fat videos I've never heard
of those guys they're just not
low-calorie
um you don't have to say every joke Hey
look there's us on YouTube subscription
that's not that's not the algorithm of
ours that's just the way it isn't all
everyone's YouTube old fat videos do we
think trolls to has killed the movie
that junky mulk oh if someone wrote a
comment in Russian that's exciting
hold on I want see their social blade
stats mmm damn they do really well I
don't wanna fall people are doing good
all right full fat videos there you go
just subscribe you you found Jabby
through us and now we found full fat
videos through you Karthik why are you
sending like the signs of the zodiac and
what not es Gd are you trying to
communicate some kind of code okay so
according to Michael B here and the chat
Naruto has concluded but there are
roughly 720 to 720 episodes
roughly Olivia Naruto has 720 episodes
you want to start this show with me what
do you mean you've already watched it
all you've already watched Yuri watching
and I can't start watching this online
and it has to be with you and you're
watching it I'm gonna calculate just how
long that would be so 22 minutes x 720
episodes divided by 24 hours I know I
have a th is way divided damn this is
hard to do by time we can't keep
starting shows on page because we just
started JoJo's bizarre adventures on
patreon and starting shows that take it
yeah zoom or patreon shut down with the
people at patreon there's no what like 5
years to do supernatural we do want to
I box at nights kidding in the chip I
box at night with is there's fillers you
can skip so we'll only have 700 episodes
all right guys all right after Hyrule
all right here highlighted all right mr.
Hyrule two things first how does one
suggest to slash submit videos for you
to react to it's simply you just say
right here and then we'll take your
suggestion and consider and put it in up
put it in the tub I'm gonna pull out an
app it's I decide every day just reach
inside raffle we just put a point of fan
at it and then yes but it's not gonna do
well let's do it anyway you can comment
in the comments but we don't do like
direct requests any any longer really a
second if we are talking favorite
youtubers you should check out mr. sark
his editing and humor well let's see not
let's see if your recommendation does
come in handy let us see mr. Sark
I am subscribe oh my god John's is what
it looks like mr. Sark boom welcome to
the party pal there we go
I will eventually check out mr. Starks
channel oh there is doing a Q&A in the
car is my collar good guy I used to
record movie reviews in the car
those were fin and everyone reviews were
you shouldn't be [ __ ] with you at
movies in the car I know her console
yeah I know I was like hands-free but
everyone's like nah no I gotta get
focused here people are pitching cavil
for Superman and RDJ for Ironman things
are getting crazy in here
Sandra okay I would love Andrew said
sexist guys ever yes
Jackson I'll answer your question is
that my favorite actor is a giant I
gotta go back to this one
sexist guys ever did you did she
actually calling us sexist no I think
there's just a missing me yeah could be
it's entirely possible if you think
we're sexist send a super she will
entertain the idea John Flickinger would
be a good job [ __ ] thing will be as
great coughs mmm-hmm
describe what Marsellus Wallace looks
like alright I'm gonna take a break from
my ice cream somebody to focus on
everyone's comments right now all right
let me take I just mean it I needed a
little bit of food I really did
thank you thank you for being patient
with me and bear with me am i my
terrible and professionalism John John's
more professional than me in every way
that is the truth true fact
thank you mister Hyrule is that you
right there by the way Peter okay
Melanie Melanie back in the game Melanie
Peter Hollens Whitney Avalon and epic
rap battles are awesome when I like to
pretend I can sing Melanie looking at
you I can tell you can sing gosh
Melanie is one of the few people one of
the few females who prefers g-train over
okay James over here oh oh well now we
got a Duke it out John bring the energy
back would you haha why I do why I go
into my mr. burns comic bye bye yes see
my this see my best to get episode yeah
okay you can only check in for so long
who else oh goodness golly eric
Horseman's back eric horseman cooking
shows avant-garde I'm sorry oh no we got
a show we got Shelby Brian and their
fellow super chatting they deserve to at
least have their profile pic and their
question truly showcase on screen I know
Thank You Erik horsemen and Thank You
Melanie by the way I I love you Melanie
Erik horsemen cooking shows avantgarde
Amin Welsh's in queues but base my
viewing habits on hotness factor
evidently interesting take he got haha
okay so how about this
all right become let's go to Whitney
Avalon from Melanie let's see who she's
recommending okay no no you just--come
[ __ ] this whole operation back six
months there we go Whitney Avalon she
related Mickey Avalon oh my god you guys
are recommending people who are so much
more famous than us what is doing or he
goes in the show's musical stuff actress
singer writer
oh [ __ ] damn Jack of mini train you know
we can't says okay so we got that at nan
Eric avant-garde vegan I'm telling you
guys though I'm gonna refresh this you
just that you are you to be a higher D
and it's just gonna be a whole bunch of
like the people you guys are recommended
that we have subscribed to while doing
this our algorithm is gonna be so
strange vegan recipes this is you you're
a pescetarian now I'm pescetarian but
I'm primarily just honestly vegetarian
most days of the week who you know there
you go
thank you Eric what is Eric's the one
who told me about the impossible
whoppers at Burger King and he is not
wrong about those man they are there
John are good China getting a lot of
love here or your long hair oh thanks I
appreciate that I built it myself I'm
telling you guys if Jon cut his hair you
would disown the [ __ ] if he
shaved his head you ago it's not worth
it ah he wasn't as special as I thought
he was it's true that's why he keeps his
hair
mm-hmm an insecurity factor really yeah
it's a conversation piece it's like ah I
have no personality of my very own and
nothing to contribute content wise to
you know anybody in the world so you
know you remember Shanghai noon when
they cut Jackie Chan's ponytail and it
sent him into a funk that because on
yeah and I will be disavowed of my rank
first John was disavow from the
Forbidden City for being a white
American your program our culture with
your long braid and now I'm just here in
America
hanging out with Cowboys I might cut it
like a little bit but not much
see John's Abe John is like Samson
Powers is hair mm-hmm they get it you're
getting Greg album John so long I used
to call you Greg albums back when we
were a little
yeah he's called me eggs and eggs yeah
well cuz you love eggs you're the eggs
guys are Hayley Hayley Hayley the take
used to be screaming prison is good film
commentary breaking down shows wait a
minute I think I'm subscribed to the
take yeah I feel like I've seen I've
gotta subscribe to the take yeah I need
to have this notification bout that
[Music]
that's a good-ass call right there
Hayley Clell where do you it we really
live now uh in Tennessee TN man hey Leah
it's so far away I know I miss you
Hayley I do too
oh okay we got tech we can keep up what
the hell are you talking about Albie oh
wow haha no John never had
sure he still had the hair coming to a
wig attached to a hat
alright John still had it alright you
still have the long hair oh my god all
doesn't love for Jonathan you know what
I mean I would love to play Wolverine I
appreciate you putting my name out there
so now my stream all right Robert
Rodriguez Citizen Kane remake is the
right thing to do
Tom Cruise for Wolverine Rio Claus will
come from his hands I bet they will he
a method actor he's gonna get them
transplanted you guys should be in a
Marvel movie but which one which Marvel
movie what characters would we be who
from the MCU fan cast us I think Tony
Gregg for Tom Cruise biopic yes Greg for
John Tom Cruise biopic I'm not mean yeah
Michael B I am not mean I don't deserve
it
exactly see he jump gets it Greg might
Greg might be mean but I don't deserve
it
brie Larson is Wolverine now that I want
there to be no no rules in Hollywood no
way I'm not caught up with Clone Wars I
had to read two books this week caught
up would you read a book segment next
time let's see here
Greg danny gonzalez i don't know who
that is uh-oh well you better track them
down John have you ever considered
cutting your hair and submitting it to
like cancer yeah actually if I can sir
mr. cancer excuse me I found a giant
crab can you have some hair no I yeah in
fact like at some point I will trim it
like I've gotten to a point in life
where I'm like I don't I used to want a
buzz cut when I was a kid so bad and I
did that for a while and now I am at the
point where I feel like a long hair
scenario is probably where I'm most
comfortable so you know once my hair
gets a bit longer and I can cut like
tenor a foot you know and still have a
good amount of length I will donate some
yeah I definitely want to do that and
that was part of like once it got to be
like you know 90s grunge bands long I
was like well okay now that I've gotten
this far I'd probably only bring it back
up to my shoulders and most so I gotta
get like the length from there you
should so see this person's got the
right idea
you should sell strands of your hair on
your patreon sure if you want see I got
hundreds of thousands of them how long
did it take you to grow your hair that
long
I probably haven't fully I haven't
gotten like a proper cut in about Oh God
maybe he's been like four or five years
and when was the last time you showered
because you really [ __ ] need one I'm
not mean my guess Corpening and stupid
hot outside my gosh and when I get
stressed about things I sweat ball um
you would buy it I know you would Thank
You Haley I know you would buy it Aneesa
I will send you some of my hair for free
oh oh oh my god where we go hmm so
scourge a is a sausage a 1999
okay favorite YouTube channels Sen top
ten top ten of course Oh John Roca
don't wanna hurt his ego cinemassacre
GMM good mythical morning true geordie
true Geordi I've heard that name I don't
know who they are true Geordi mmm let's
hear let's see let's go let's take it a
little adventure guys come with us
my we're gonna be introduced so many new
to town we're gonna have an entirely
different viewing catalog guys
everyone's getting so mad about these
lots of us two weeks and I'm telling you
just wait for the actual game to come
out before you get mad at where you're
hearing yeah like especially unless
you're in that medium I mean yeah I mean
what I've heard hasn't got me excited
boaters wait curious about what you've
heard but I don't feel like I should ask
I guess I know no we're trying to act
like you actually play things but I am
gonna catch up with it
yeah Devil May Cry 4 oh yeah yeah when
when as soon as I get the TV oh yeah my
room to work yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah in
fact you guys gave me that TV I gave you
that TV yeah you guys me that's a [ __ ]
built that T it's a [ __ ] mean I am to
John goddamn television yeah it was
brand-new when you bought it
people are saying we're skipping the
Super chats and I'm like
we haven't skipped the super chats oh
wait a minute did we skip this one I
don't think so
I've read that in a silly quiz you read
that in The Voice we read we talked
about the Hercules remake one we're just
a little bit behind don't worry don't
worry we're gonna get to everyone
especially it's your birthday there's no
way we're gonna miss yours Kartik Louise
oh my god Louise my favorite my favorite
super chats so far Jabby who I only know
Greg but a Chara is fav Oh Thank You
Lois ass moment of love for a Chara
thank you a Chara is is special she's
very she's super sweet and under
appreciated by the community mm-hmm the
black community especially appreciate
her morning yeah guy is saying guys a
lot for you guys she's a trailblazer in
the black she really is
I can't add this no I would love to play
Joel Miller thank you I appreciate the
vote of confidence a lot like Gerard
Butler and Hugh Jackman I would love to
use my hair as a superpower to take down
enemies too patty Mayo I have heard of
yes Greg is Captain America
you guys are assigning me for all like
the great superheroes and I really
appreciate it right above your Harley
Quinn John would be like rocket raccoon
or something or whoever [ __ ] Thor's
team was in the first two Thor movies
that gets killed off and the Ragnarok
like they're [ __ ] nothing
so I'm Zachary Levi but at least I'll
get to go have a DC movie as moderately
as a moderate success I will sell shall
I'm gonna say yes I'm gonna sell my
shampoo what just join me on only fans
and buy my hair and shampoo and kyon
okay she's saying we skip that one I
don't see that anywhere here kyon and JC
huh I don't see it anywhere
hold on we can do a word search right
yeah I guess so but not over here learn
delivery gosh you know I'm trying to
yeah it's not there I'm sorry it's not
there Nyssa I don't know what you're
talking about but it ain't there you
know JC in here okay how about this guys
let me ask you let me ask you this which
youtuber out there right now do you
think I'm asking the audience this I'm
looking at the chats who do you think
which youtuber out there right now do
you think has the potential to become
like the next big movie saw or filmmaker
you know like like Bo Burnham like Bo
Burnham is the only one I can really
think of who went from YouTube sensation
to respectable filmmaker slash comedian
who out there right now do you think
will be that next one to hit the stride
I'm thinking it's one of the rack Iraq
against whatever is the one who directly
in the Eli Roth movie one of those guys
filthy Frank
filthy Frank for sure filthy Frank
actually before seeing Sally Sally
Lomonaco brown re Jane filthy Frank
actually has a very successful music
career now is Joe G
Tyrone Magnus maybe real Reed matpat
Matt pads a good call
yeah put this bird I've seen a lot of
Brandon rogers thrown out mighty raccoon
mighty raccoon struggle nation you know
struggle nation has really stuck to
their guns I'm making more like short
films and stuff and yeah as opposed to
doing reactions I mean yeah another
doing I forgot it
they left the noggin right then and
there if I had Marshall wires getting
there yes if I was wearing a wife-beater
right now I would
get off and I would be a Nick Cage from
Connor free just for you though
Shane top from Smosh good call good call
jacksepticeye you know it seems like
jacksepticeye is the one who's getting
the most yeah the most attention who's
the guy who makes the loop music on the
youtubes he does like long live streams
and he's got two L's somewhere in his
name comment he's funny
I like him a lot oh I watch scheme yes I
am
no not not ksi i watch Steve Terry Barry
sometimes when I want to watch you like
pure crack come to life Michael B we got
two back to backs from you buddy
look out honestly it's this channel is
my favorite one next to mine of course
personal biases and why Michael be
approached it's like there are two of
them personal biases and all also Sam
didn't take your birthday advice she
didn't give you the anal I'm sorry
right Oh remember Robbie Amell Stephen
Amell as shag you Oh Robbie Amell is
Fred it's Stephen Amell shaggy both of
them yeah I get it
well thank you Michael B for a for your
contribution B appreciate the
compliments dude I'm sorry about your
girlfriend not taking your advice but
still keep her she's the best you're
ever gonna get Michael B I was saying
also Robbie Amell has Fred and Stephen
Amell is shaggy Fred Flintstone Fred
whatever see yes reserves from limp
Biskit understand then shaggy
Norville shaggy Rogers yeah wait a
minute prof did we I'll keep an eye out
for your name on the comments here John
yeah we may be a little behind but I
think we'll get to you unless you are
like way back not even oh you're not
even going off a Michael B's comment
here you're just completely small I'm
sorry somebody said we missed there
someone who's not nice that's us then we
gotta at least not just read it but
actually acknowledge it and give some
type of back and forth right
yes yes of course Fred from the mystery
guys what'd he do this and Shaggy and
the Amell brothers and they'll audition
on American Gladiators there that's all
it took yeah we did it
but next time keep it 100 percent I will
I'm sorry I'm sorry might give you a
hundred percent I'm sorry all right
myself start changing the subject in the
middle of I'm sorry let me tighten my
Sealy kale quick I'm sorry Michael B
we're trying to give proper attention in
this [ __ ]
Rashid Baruti is a legend but Michael B
is an even bigger legend all right
so John's make clap clap hmm
we really should just set a standard of
we're only gonna look for 35 minutes
it's not gonna happen there you go a
live stream will have 35 minutes and
college now he is what do you mean I'm
where you call me fat no only that fat
that don't get you are the protagonist
you get the girl and I'm your trusty
sidekick who makes waffles
you're not my trusty sidekick you know
you're your [ __ ] Farquaad I'm short
and unfortunate you're short in here and
voiced by John Lithgow I have sort of
heart shorten here it is a my shirt is
from an isa birthday girl Oliva and it's
a tree with a heart and a clock and a
Sun and a little pendulum okay no Bill
Cosby no I'm sorry look you you guys
gotta like send us the comments in the
super chat like it's something that
could be good three years from now that
way
it'll get to the point where yeah we'll
have to answer super chats in the next
live stream and those keep rolling over
and over you see I want to acknowledge
something right here because it's an
camera for your next guy that the thing
is like we've had to resort to doing
like intro bits for a while we were
doing that as like part of the sketches
as like part of the sketch
like maybe we could just make some funny
intros we were doing that pretty
assistant Lee for a while instead of
full-on sketches so that was like
supplemental scratches but you know and
also you're kind of right where doof
we're overdue for another proper sketch
once we can get some other people in
here we need help filming those it's not
just John and I we tried that for the
last time Star Wars yeah the Star Wars
probably there's probably chocolate on
my mic and this week for the Star Wars
the rise of Skywalker one we tried doing
that by ourselves really like [ __ ] we
could do this one by ourselves the other
ones who like having like one person or
another Joker was the one we're real
like we can do this ourselves right and
then after like an hour to really
catonian yeah yeah no we there from the
beginning knows Rises Skywalker oh we
did come for that one rise of
Skywalker's what we're doing by
ourselves and then we were realizing
this is taking way too long
we just had a third person in here it's
a lot when you're like try to get the
frame down especially when both of us
are in the shot is actually like really
hard to get hello it's called a tripod
and a living hahahaha Michael V hey
she's held behind scenes more times so
many she is our our secret weapon like
the idea behind like the funny interest
of what I mean is like what we did for
the sole trailer reaction like I
scripted that one like there's still
script to like we're still reading it
out and I had an edit in mind or like
the flash video where I'm choking Olivia
at the top like that was it's like five
seconds long but that's still like a bit
that you know it took time to figure out
how to [ __ ] do that you know so yeah
Olivia's not the tripod olivia is a
centerpiece and were the legs out out to
Egypt that's right we do have merch we
just never wear them it's on Spreadshirt
slash the real rejects about a different
company ya know that'll be the day or
promote them I think I wrote them yeah I
think designed by humans
rates through YouTube so I need to come
up with a Batman sketch I do need to
come up with one don't worry you've got
a year to do it
got a year until the Batman even thinks
about maybe coming but I appreciate the
love you guys give on the sketches
honestly that's what helped that
infinity war one that was the first time
we ever hit the trending page was the
infinity war trailer reaction I know
that sketch was a big part of it and
endgame as well
PJ back in the chat sound cut out when
when who said that is it I think I just
fixed it
think I fixed it I think I unplugged it
I'm sorry no for a second I thought
alpha wolf was April where we are we not
wait John your sounds out to start Rick
says it's good are we good now good I
know but if Michael B and Erica are
saying it's bad and it's bad alright
alright we can't let down one person one
person this is why any time there's a
single hate comment I up right there we
go okay thanks all good now all right
we're good it's all good now
people-pleasing complete we don't have
to stress any longer all right here we
are Pete as much as I love Captain
America I own the Winter Soldier and cap
shield care sevens is really really good
in defending Jacob you know Chris Evans
is actually a really great actor and I
don't think enough people are giving him
the chin like really going out of their
way to check him out so PJ I want to
thank you for porting out the Chris
Evans is really good in the his work in
defending Jacob also want to point out I
have no idea what the [ __ ] you're
talking about is that the Apple thing
really not sure which one he's talking
about all I've heard is that snowpiercer
is great watch Snow piercer also
cellular cellular yeah Stephen King
alright
Felicia Stephen King asked Elisha
Cuthbert Jason Statham what are you
talking about it's not based on a
Stephen King novella or something is it
cellular I don't know I could be wrong
that could be mistaken cellular who else
was in that besides Chris Evans Kim
Basinger it's based on a book or
something right isn't it William each
Maisie Noah Emmerich Jessica Biel I
guess I'm just completely wrong yeah
well that's what people like you John
because you have long hair that's it
yes and no brains and babies to make up
for that John when you when you yes and
my mean comments and don't defend
yourself that I just look like a bully
you told me to guess and earlier in the
stream I'm just all this your father was
like a bully yeah I know it is I'm sorry
that's my fault
yeah rush-hour remake would be terrific
I want that me me em see
JB Taylor's got my back you're thinking
of sell it's based on a Stephen King
novel got your back yeah it's got your
back wait it was corrected your ass he
corrected but but corrected it and
rekted it thus proving I was at least in
the neighborhood of correctness yeah
what I got clean pop filter I am never
using that mic is it just as good as the
ice cream was used to hearing that
outside of a coffeehouse
if you're that gross you should see me
lick ranch off my table when I do it
falls off my my chickens my oh my let's
go back to the super chat like why
didn't you answer my question Mimi M woo
what's she saying how come we're not pop
okay there we are musical revue Channel
Tyrell vibe via lost in Vegas Las Vegas
John ban splaining is a music history
channel have you heard the savage remix
featuring Beyonce I have not but I know
everyone's been freaking about it Wow
look that up Mimi I'm she's she's at her
patreon page isn't she yes sir
Mimi am you're so sweet Mimi M yeah
she's a very active indeed you know Mimi
M once sent me a love letter really yeah
and she was really Mimi and was telling
me a lot of her really provocative
thoughts mm-hmm
come to find out that there was actually
addressed to you know goodness and uh I
can't tell you guys how many times
that's happened you know it's okay I
mean one day you'll get one that's
addressed to you on purpose how happy
you'll be it's good story we got we got
twenty minutes okay good thing you did
not reschedule your therapy for 8:00
p.m. I know my sister Chev Chelios I
would love to play chef Julio's my long
hair I guess pulls chicks but I feel
like Gregg's guns do too all right where
are we at here oh look Mimi's gonna send
you a in an appropriate note I will send
you one to Greg told you sent me one
yeah that's that's good now I won't be
um I'll be jealous but that's okay if
you need to sleep I don't blame you we
need to see I think what I think about
the more is coming move yeah that's
correct
I think it's I want about time I want to
find my friends who have the most social
anxiety in the most stage fright and put
them on the live strip yeah watch have a
like yes speed round through this
uncomfortable to finish those live
stream Anissa Riverdale reactions have
been on hold since it took forever for
season three and a half to get on
Netflix guys I don't think they'll
return unfortunately my hair actually is
like down here now but it is it is chaos
in this weather like my curls are just
that they are not cooperating
any hope let's go back to here John is
the doctor and Gregor's Rose Tyler
Jesse that's right baby I'm the doctor
so you know your rose
[ __ ] I right or wrong rose man go jump
into Janice's arms Lee Haeri to deal
with this empty child on my own hungry
23 says Greg you remind me of Ryan
Reynolds
I don't flat on my ears I pull it back
really [ __ ] hard
that's that reminded me of and okay okay
got everyone in the chat is saying they
need to go to bed eventually so we're
gonna give back today somebody wants
your hair though Aneesa does anyway
chill level TV all right chill level TV
thank you dear let's check this out
watch it
let's check this out give a coin to your
watcher watcher boom subscribe focus on
creating television caliber unscripted
reality I love it thank you chill level
TV appreciate your contribution oh my
God look we got a speed round from
Anissa here get ready for a John what
shirt is your favorite shirt this shirt
this shirt I love that you know whenever
I wear this shirt I used to go to the
gym and it's not because I got lazy guys
it's because of quarantine so this is G
so I got this shirt and I said the
matrix this is documentary I got this
from Anissa and whenever I wear this
shirt in public people always like cool
shirt bro cool shirt hey Bo and and then
I don't I don't like they're like
where'd you get it and I'm like this
freaking sexy
ER person works in Texas and I've always
seen exactly like that too and this is
saying
daniel Jones things you're more awesome
than me I just had 1 out of 10 Thank You
Daniel chance you should become an ASMR
channel now I will this is saying you
should become an ASMR channel you know
what market is completely untapped as
ASMR movie news and I will I will read
you the news as if I am tickling your
ears and speaking very close ooh
thank you an ism Oh John John look yes
right supremacy yes what I strive for
you guys should don't worry guys
one day I'm gonna leave this channel
behind it's gonna go right into John's
hands and it's night into the ground no
no I guarantee you it's gonna be better
than ever
I appreciate your cry to you guys not
only fans for machine it's not gonna
work because the bit is I mean to John
because I think John is better than me
all right and he explained you what's
going on so that makes me look bad and
pitiful
so people are showing John love right
now
now all the positivity is going to him
because I look desperate for attention
and if I look desperate for attention
and then the love you give me is only
gonna look like pity love please love me
that's so that's that's my act now the
question is is it really an act this
presupposes is what if he didn't
[ __ ]
humors based effect you didn't cry the
innovating game you are a monster and
then this is also saying are you all
subscribed to jab be coy or do you know
him personally
just wondering wait a minute how well do
you know us he's my brother brother he
does my actual biological older brother
he is the brother we built for you he
doesn't acknowledge me as his brother
but I know he's my brother and I'm gonna
prove it one day I swear it if it's the
last thing I do
one day he's going to he's gonna he's
gonna go Greg Alba from the real rejects
he's my brother
please clapping but I'm telling you he
won't he won't say that in private
conversations at networking events
around family but he really is guys
Jabbok away he's my brother so I just
wish he felt that what
and Anissa Oliver is also saying Greg
yes I want to agree with that mr. Lewis
is saying Greg do you play the guitar if
not John show him he taught me
everything I know
yeah I do play the guitar
grab my third grade guitar I don't play
as often as John I haven't played in
months but you know John is a pretty
incredible guitar player there's no
denying that there's no denying that
exceptionally better than me in every
[ __ ] way beyond guitar but especially
in guitar I will Pat my back on one
thing that I think I might have up on
John when it comes to guitar mm-hmm can
you guess what that is I have two in
mind yes John you are more proficient at
singing and playing an entire song in
unison and you have literally written a
hundred percent more songs than I so I
wasn't thinking about the singing part
but I've gotten better I'm pretty I'm
like for Olivia's birthday they're the
first birthday we ever I ever have was
fortunate enough to share with her I was
like I want to relearn guitar for her
birthday to write her a song I relearned
guitar in a month and I wrote her a song
and a week yeah now that [ __ ] was I was
always very marveled by the fact that
you really got the singing playing part
down fast were like that that's
impressive to me because that's hard
like I had to work really hard to get to
that you know well I mean guys you
should see John's
finger picking techniques ladies oh you
hear that that's Alex
wait wait recent developing or pick yeah
real guitar guitar hero and guitar are
almost nothing so if you're gonna spend
it on getting good I would pick the real
one all right guys we're almost here and
to whoever
asked in the comments who's not a patron
I love Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
it was my first reentry into like
full-on anime series and yeah I think
it's terrific it's really well told
story a lot of really great subtext a
lot of really great you know thrills in
action and art and all sorts of stuff I
don't remember what your question was
I'm sorry just send it again I'll leave
Erik horseman is back back in the game
okay you are horribly sexist hashtag me
- oh yes we argue he knows it and that's
why I knew so liver loves us oh that's
right we'll come to us for the sexy will
come to us because they go hey he's
strong all right
react and you don't get you don't really
see them on YouTube they really are
encroaching on our rights as Matt they
really speak to us they really speak for
the alright sjw's holding us down yeah
man brie larson women in film or hate
women Professor Archer as they please
recommend some good thriller TV shows or
movies
oh my god thank you for that question
professor hardware I'm on season three
of the hit series that got canceled
early because didn't get enough ratings
Hannibal Hannibal watch that show it's
[ __ ] good and I recently finally I'm
so late I tried watching the show like
15 years ago and then I just and I
started to watch it yesterday it's
Olivia's favorite one of her favorite
shows ever The Sopranos
um holy [ __ ] I don't know why I didn't
like him like I mean thought I didn't
like it I just didn't really appreciate
it and then this last time watching it
was like gripped by it I was laughing a
lot it is so good but Hannibal that's if
you're looking for something like a
really cool well-told character driven
intense stylistic thriller Hannibal for
sure
John recommend something recommend
recommend something John alright let's
see why long the long waiting prosper
demmick that's a great romantic thriller
thank God you got the long hair vertigo
thriller what Wally Phil its quality
thriller the bird that's a real
landscape Hitler I'll need more
thrillers if you want me to I know I
don't want to look like Jesus I guess I
can okay yes you got your recommendation
it's not Archer action thriller the rate
yeah all right and then okay its ruler
TV series that's a tougher one
I recommend Josh GAD Channel really he's
got a channel he's reuniting the cast of
The Goonies on his channel apparently is
he mmm-hmm it's been the talk of the
town this week
wait so Finn wolfhard and Jack Dillon
grazer felis yes all of them and then
Bobby Brown Bobby Brown - oh man
Baker Montgomery I had a dream
thank you and this up by the way I
didn't know Josh GAD had a channel thank
you I had a dream that one day what a
dream that I went to an early opening of
Halloween Horror Nights and I got to go
with the stranger things cast through
the stranger things maze Oh Millie Bobby
Brown was very nice to me oh that was
literally Patriots day if she recognized
me from It's Always Sunny wouldn't that
be nice oh goodness yeah oh hey fam fail
tail yes good call slow mo guys are
awesome yes thank you thank you for
mentioning that maybe hasn't seen slow
mo guys [ __ ] fantastic Channel Olivia
introduce earnest Lomo guys and and she
says but also shaving people 20 things
but you got a lot to watch them sorry
what the supernatural saving people
hunting things instead of saving Oh
hunting things we got with this guys way
too hairy oh yeah that would be add well
and the episode we recorded today
actually it wouldn't be too far from the
truth saving Jensen's palms there
professor Archer saying would like to
you guys more to see you that's what the
eyeballs mean to see you guys [ __ ] G
Abby's channel mm-hmm yes yes I would
love to be on Jabby channel more but the
thing is he keeps talking over me and I
don't like that you know what I mean
John thing yeah yeah you get it I think
I can understand where I'm coming from
on that one right yeah that's a bit make
sense guys I know I'm not gonna
interrupt you the time I promise all
right all right
yeah Jabby Jericho a doesn't have us on
very often well he's like he tried
getting John to do a podcast with him
and I said don't you take John away from
me yeah he's already stressed out enough
as it is handling [ __ ] here
now you're gonna stress him out more by
bringing him on your podcast what you're
gonna pay him more to be there wait a
minute he'd make more money going on
your podcast he's not gonna come back to
the real rejects no don't do it
and that's the story of how I didn't do
that by John now I don't co-host that
[ __ ] let it go a podcast with your
brother at some point when life is a
when I when I've that's tired of movies
I'm gonna find the jab ehrs meme
Instagram page all right well thank you
professor Archer I would love to go back
on that channel Eric or uh nope Ron beak
the 3rd Ozzie man thank you honey man is
he like an Australian man who has a
channel is that
or is it an Ozzy Osbourne impersonators
channel I'll tell you right now John is
in Ozzie and Harriet guys Chen right now
or is it
you guys are soo dr. Oz's channel not
gonna love the channel about the shell
Oz from HBO or Frank Oz's vlog series
Ozzie man reviews hey beluga whale vs.
seagull should not be into this do it
these are honestly the channels I watch
like here I'll show you guys are you
guys can I don't know how well you guys
can see this Tommy was though mm-hmm but
look at what's in our this is let's say
Omni media who just super chatted us
sandwich or deer right there in the
notification bells you're perfect
Graham Stephen talks a lot about real
say dodgy and looper Cynthia Rothrock
where's that there's this channel I
subscribe to you recently that does like
these [ __ ] like like top 10 most
terrifying human diseases you ever see
or top 10 most mystical animals the I
didn't intend to sleep tonight anyway
are these right here is that it over
before you go yeah top 5 best I love
them heard it here first
um Ozzie man just subscribe thank you
thank you Ron beak that there you Eric
horseman is saying to us what the [ __ ]
is going on here what are you doing John
your saw The Sixth Sense poster on your
phone I know what are you doing I was
reminding myself of some thrillers
because I wanted to be able to answer it
better if it ever comes up again
[ __ ]
but Eric horseman is a question stop
wasting time what the [ __ ] is going on
here drunk is [ __ ] can't keep up
how can you not keep them all we take so
long per question how can you knock you
what gives green room is a great
thriller that's for you
Eric horseman is so funny guys so funny
I can't wait to sleep you're in one day
you're my hahaha because what my
question will be then
if that happens will it have been an
intentional thing on both of your parts
or just like something that you both
wake up and are like oh what happened oh
now I have a real rejects Tatem to a lot
of people ask him to Robby Q are famous
as [ __ ] right now you [ __ ]
oh and look at that beard man I know oh
my God look forgot we got another one
another couple from the birthday girl
another couple from the birthday girl
another couple from the birthday girl in
the birthday world getting shot Martha
Wayne's dad
don't leave us for the pod shabby coway
we're about to answer more of your
questions and he's so gift I mean some I
know I was being sarcastic
I'm now being sarcastic Craig that's how
we Instagram a video chatted with her
John showed her his penis and she has a
hardcore Texas accent
I know Jabby is your brother I know you
very well I even know your social
security numbers oh yeah
super chat me my social security numbers
right now and I will tell you if that's
correct y'all sing super chat the amount
that our that our social security number
I wanna hear I'm only okay I'll since
you're from Texas I'll sing in my Johnny
Cash boys beanie meaning my joaquin
phoenix doing Johnny Cash voice since
you're from Texas - you all right happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
John Becca buckles happy birthday dear
Ernest happy birthday to you couldn't
find the harmony but now I've been
talking for almost three hours think I'm
gonna really sing no I was blaming
myself for not finding harmony you did a
great job I was amazing wasn't hurt I
was too good I was too good I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm doing just reacting
I got the talent don't set the bar too
high do you may Michael be wet
I made the Michael be wet on the wet
deck with a slip neck
oh hey Yuri I called out once for having
bars all right
bars with the two-car M&M with the bars
and the two cars going against the Latin
in Jafar and Mufasa and Skaar going down
to the Tar Pits while I take a [ __ ]
willing biscuit Triscuits with a floppy
disk in my chest it's Michael Jordan
hiring [ __ ] which seems quarkons
warden warden all the basketballs
Michael Jordan warden in a house with
change coordinates didn't kill my lizzie
borden brisket a lot of the credit has
to go when that guy made an identifiable
reps yeah when you gave like referenced
by the guy you created a parody of yeah
read it credit does go to him for that
especially oh my god
guys we've caught up since for 28 2011
32 a.m. since javi is the older brother
technically technically makes him the
Greg prototype all this Greg prototype
with a lot of hype Michael B and I talk
on skype have you got no grace Michael
be taking a pee in a tree thanks Bruce
Lee thank you Michael B dr. sleep is
pretty decent I've heard the directors
cuts better happy I would believe that
not into it
Keira by asking Carol Baskin be flapping
up Carol Baskin jizz it into a napkin in
the casket dannion blast it all right
and sing sing anis
and then we're gonna in this life you
wanna like throw down some relaxation
bars go to a deep sleep knee-deep
knee-deep the RAM John looks over you
like a creep here sheep oh I think we've
reached peak peak insanity we're at
three hours to God nudes to send you
Anissa yeah we got noosa sent you you've
been so incredible to us naked together
thank you loved you being in the live
stream Jackson roller you're a beautiful
person a shoe Punjabi I think was the
one who thought you had bars so a good
night to you Rainn Wilson for president
agreed this is the best con we got all
night they don't sound like him and now
that is a huge wait a minute
somebody broke into his house Eminem
self yeah what did he do I don't know
somebody just asked if we'd rather sit
on the toilet me me I'm closing a Sammy
the Angela Wallace is also great there
we go it's alright description get this
going let's get this going yeah John
type Indiana Wallace I forgot a copy and
paste you just had her him dan what is
low what is it a guy girl there's a hot
guy super hot guy whoa what the [ __ ]
there's two of them whoa whoa Daniel
Wallace Mia Wallace Wallace got heavy
wallets got a phone you better call it
somebody wants you to adopt them I think
that's the best I will adopt them yes
kim jeong-hoon is dead he's a robot now
he's like imitation crabs if you ever
watched funny and Nisa thank you so much
all right guys we're gonna call it a
night the reason we did it
on Thursday night as opposed to Friday
or Saturday is because this is when
friends used to air every episode on NBC
on the seat there's that now as a stupid
joke Dennis why can't we as live Aneesa
has been an incredible supporter of us
for such a long time and today's her
birthday so start off by saying happy
birthday to her wanted to end this so
they're giving her another happy
birthday because she's someone who means
the world to us is very special so it's
like yeah I mean Saturday is the last
four more times usually we got
everything wrapped up so it was like
yeah we're wrapped up with everything we
got videos ready to go up on Sunday
we're good but we had a promise and that
was the livestream Thursday and you guys
made a success these are always [ __ ]
weird and they're always strange they're
always off the rails and kooky I never
know where they're gonna go
but they find then people come back like
I'm looking at all these chats and
thinking about Tom a black eye I'm also
thinking um what I'm thinking about is
that two-tier complement and I realize
like super sweet things to us at the
same time in here and I'm always like
really I mean things are the insanities
or strange thing so you guys stick
around the whole time and it just means
a lot and I appreciate you sticking
around sound off all of our three our
troopers sound off you can air BnB at
John's house they have a guest room
that's right it's right especially right
don't even wait two weeks it's come on
out just come on out room over here but
ya know you should come out to LA be a
total blast John will pump you up at the
gas station anyway
love everyone being
happy birthday Anissa thank you you're
our family and Issa thank you
go buy yourself something at this point
thank you and he said thank you everyone
contribute to this super chat and thank
you very one for just uh
being yourselves being here showing the
love shows what happens when my hair
looks like when it's in the ponytail all
day for the last 12 hours it's a style
it's a style in fact somebody was that
commenting on how nice your hair looked
in the earlier video today yeah honestly
if you just created a center part I
don't think it's a bad look but if you
just yeah part it in the center you know
let it fall on the sides like Tim Burton
I don't know you look like you got your
hair in a ponytail all day if you
combine Tim Burton and Jared Padalecki
good night guys tonight people we love
you thanks for support see you next week